So Leute, das war schon 10.50 Uhr, aber ging nicht früher.
Das Ding ist ein bisschen zu laut, oder?
Boah, geht eigentlich.
Dann muss ich es leiser machen.
Warum geht dieser komische Lautstärkeregler eigentlich nur in so merkwürdigen Schritten?
Warum können die den nicht einfach mehr Zwischenschritte spendieren?
Man weiß es nicht.
Es gibt eine Sudoku-Weltmeisterschaft, was es nicht alles gibt, oder?
Ach ja, Leute, wir müssen heute mal gucken.
Nicht, dass ich mein Noisegate so hoch eingestellt habe.
Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test.
Okay, das ist die Lautstärke.
Also wenn ich leiser als so rede, geht das Noisegate an und macht das Ganze aus.
A ist am Arsch.
Nee, machen wir nicht.
Ja, ich glaube.
Da bin ich in der Regel immer drüber.
Also falls ich irgendwie abgehackt bin, müsst ihr mir das sagen.
Irgendwie sehe ich keine Vieweranzahl in meinem Twitch.
Warte mal, ich muss mal refreshen.
Jawoll.
Sehr gut, jetzt geht's.
Jetzt geht's.
69 Viewer.
Pock.
Ja.
Also Leute, ich habe heute Morgen ein bisschen auf dem Tablet.
Als ich aufgewacht bin, habe ich gerade schon ein bisschen auf dem Tablet auf YouTube rumgeguckt.
Und ich hatte eine Videoempfehlung, die ich unbedingt gucken wollte.
Und zwar, oh, Joke Gaming.
Offi, oh, Official.
Nicht einfach nur irgendwie so.
Dankeschön, Twitch Prime.
Poggers.
Moment, wo ist mein Subscriber-Sound?
Da stimmt was nicht.
Warte mal.
Mein Subscriber-Sound ist weg.
Hier.
Ja.
Findet ihr das auch so bescheuert?
Dass man auf Twitch.
Jetzt erstens die ganze Seite irgendwie in schwarz hat.
Und dass man auch, wenn man auf ein Profil von jemand geht.
Ich war heute Morgen auf meinem Profil.
Dass man überhaupt nichts mehr sieht.
Eines der ersten Sachen, die mich interessieren bei den Leuten, ist immer.
Zum Beispiel, wie viel Subs und wie viele Follower und so haben sie.
Das sieht man nicht mehr.
Da muss man erst hier draufklicken.
Total beknackt.
Und ich verstehe auch nicht.
Warum?
Warum haben sie das hier so komisch gemacht?
Übrigens, das Beste, was ihr installieren könnt.
Ohne Mist.
Es geht leider halt nur auf dem Desktop.
Das Beste, was ihr installieren könnt, ist das hier.
Wir installieren das hier gerade mal.
Wir gucken uns das mal zusammen an.
Das ist das Beste, was ihr installieren könnt.
Hier.
Franker Faces.
In your Faces.
Z.
So.
Und wenn ihr das Ganze dann refresht.
Dann habt ihr hier unten.
Das da.
Das Control Panel.
Und da könnt ihr einschalten.
Stellen Theme.
Beste.
Da stellt ihr ein Background das da.
Ups.
Background das da.
Und schon sieht das wieder gut aus.
Das alte, das alte Theme geht übrigens nicht mehr richtig.
Das ist kaputt.
Das müsst ihr einstellen.
Das sieht ja schon mal wieder viel besser aus.
Und dann ist auch noch eine wichtige Geschichte, was ihr einstellen müsst.
Zumindest das stelle ich immer so ein.
Wo ist Freund?
Chat.
Okay.
Erst mal muss man ganz wichtig.
Man muss Gifs einstellen.
Einschalten.
Wo ist das denn?
Bin ich jetzt total bescheuert?
Das ist halt ein übelst, übelst lange Chat hier.
Genau.
Highlight Messages that mention you.
Muss man einstellen.
Dass man direkt gehighlight wird, wenn er an jemanden anschreibt.
Das ist wichtig.
So.
Und dann haben wir bei.
Die haben das umsortiert.
Das sieht irgendwie anders aus.
Bei Player.
Das da müsst ihr ausschalten.
Dass euch die ganzen Extensions nicht auf den Keyboard.
Nicht auf den Keyboard.
Gehen.
Weil ansonsten.
Übrigens ihr könnt auch.
Ihr könnt auch bei Theme könnt ihr auch.
Die alte die alte Schrift wieder einstellen.
Wenn ihr die alte Schrift haben wollt das macht ihr einfach so.
Hier habt ihr wieder die alte Schrift.
So.
Bits.
Das kann man alles einstellen.
Das machen wir aus.
Dann ist der Chat größer.
Den Rest lassen wir an.
Addons bei der Twitch TV muss an.
Give Emotes
Animated
So, ich glaube das war es im Großen und Ganzen
Ihr könnt noch einen Highlight Sound einstellen
Das mache ich allerdings nicht an
Weil mir das immer auf den Sack geht
Sound wet
Genau, so muss man das Ganze einstellen
Schon ist Twitch wieder viel benutzbarer
Was ich noch ganz gerne mache
Ist bei Player
Bei, ne passt
Ne, alles gut
Das war es
Die Settings braucht ihr
Und das Beste ist, wenn jetzt euer Twitch
Wenn jetzt euer Twitch mal rumspackt
Okay, wir gehen mal auf einen anderen Channel
Sonst ist das übertrieben verwirrend
Wir gehen jetzt hier Bob Ross
Gehen wir jetzt mal rein
Wenn euer Player mal wieder rumspacken sollte
Der spackt übrigens
So eine T-Media, müssen wir mal gucken
Ne, macht es nicht
Wenn euer Player rumspacken sollte, dann könnt ihr einfach hier draufklicken
Doppelklick
Und dann resetet der Player
Dann müsst ihr nicht das komplette Fenster neu laden
Was euer Chat auch neu lädt
Ah ja, und übrigens auch ein ganz tolles neues Feature
Wenn ich jetzt hier in den Chat reinschreibe
Fuck, ich bin nicht angemeldet
Wenn man jetzt in den Chat reinschreibt
Irgendwas
Dann kann man mit Pfeiltaste hoch und runter
Das wieder aufrufen
Was man zuvor geschrieben hat
Das heißt, wenn ihr eure Lieblings-Copypastas
Einmal Copypastat habt
Könnt ihr einfach hier in die History gehen
Ja, ich muss mich anmelden, ich weiß
Einfach in die History gehen
Und guckt hoch und runter
Seht ihr Leute, ich drücke jetzt die Taste hoch
Und runter
Und da kriege ich meine alten
Chat-Nachrichten
Ich bin halt nicht angemeldet
Kann ich jetzt durchschalten
Das ist richtig gut
Twitch in Twitch
Yo Dog
I put your Twitch in Twitch
For Twitch Chat
In Ofen
Ja, so
Zumindest ganz tolle Geschichte
Kann ich jedem nur empfehlen
Besser als bei der Twitch-TV
Franker in your Faces Z
Beste
Ihr könnt euch mal angucken
Was es sonst noch für Möglichkeiten gibt
Man konnte das Fenster irgendwo mal größer machen
Ah, Settings New Window
Ja, ist viel besser
Ihr seht, das Ding hat massig viele
Massig viele verschiedene Settings
Ja, also ihr könnt da wirklich Twitch einstellen
Wie ihr wollt
Was auch ganz cool ist
Man kann einstellen, dass hier zum Beispiel
Ähm
Wobei, ich glaube, das ist mittlerweile Twitch-Standard
Dass man sich die Zeit davor anzeigen lassen kann
Ich weiß nicht, ob das
Jetzt ist die Musik zu laut, oder?
Kann die Musik sich mal überlegen, wie laut sie sein möchte?
That's okay
So, also man sieht schon
Das Ding hat wirklich sau viele Optionen
Ihr könnt alles so einstellen
Man kann den Chat auch noch customizen
Was
Schriftart und
Abstände angeht
Das ist eigentlich auch ganz cool
Man kann, man konnte irgendwo sagen, dass es nicht so laut ist
Also man hat für für Moderatoren hat man auch Quick Actions
Das ist schöner
Ähm
Zu moderieren
Aber man kann, was auch ganz nice ist
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wo sie das mittlerweile haben
Man konnte irgendwo einstellen
Ach ja, das ist auch cool
Das ist richtig geil
Also passt mal auf
Ähm
Ich, ich lösche jetzt mal meine eigene Message hier, ne?
Lull
Kann ich, kann ich mal überhaupt meine eigene Message löschen?
Ich kann meine eigene Message nicht, nicht löschen
Ähm
Ja, neue Emotes
Ja, neue Emotes, ne?
So, genau
Ich lösche jetzt, lösche jetzt von
Ähm, ich lösche euch hier Message mal
Und jetzt sieht man hier
Message deleted
Normalerweise ist die weg
Aber mit FFZ kann man draufklicken
Und man sieht sie wieder
Das heißt, wenn ihr sehen wollt, was die Leute für
Für Bullshit schreiben
Dann könnt ihr mit FFZ das nachträglich gucken
Auch wenn es den Moderator gelöscht hat
Das ist dann aber nur für euch, ne?
Das ist nicht irgendwie im Chat oder so
Das ist dann nur für euch
Das finde ich ist eines der besten Features, was es da überhaupt gibt
Ja, die Funktion gibt es auch bei der Twitch-TV und bei FFZ gibt es schon ewig
Aber was auch noch ganz nice ist
Ich finde es jetzt nicht mal
Man kann den Chat besser lesbar machen
Man kann einstellen, dass die Nachrichten
Äh, leicht unterschiedliche Farben kriegen
Die nacheinander gepostet werden
Das heißt, man kann die viel besser
Viel besser unterscheiden
Ich finde es jetzt aber gerade nicht
Weil das echt
Übelst, ähm
Genau, so
Das meine ich
Das ist echt praktisch
Das benutze ich in Chats, wo viel los ist
Ähm, man kann
Man kann die Emotes noch einstellen
Aber, ja gut, da nehme ich immer Standard
Das ist praktisch
Und wenn man mehr Text in das Fenster reinkriegen will
Ist das auch noch eine ganz coole Kombi
Und das ist echt nice
Weil so kann man die Nachrichten gut unterscheiden
Und es passt mehr Text rein
In das gleiche Fenster
Also das ist wirklich ordentlich
Ordentlich Poggers
Ja, und man kann Emojis umstellen
Was man, was man verwenden will
Ja, so ist das
Also kann ich
Nein
Ich weiß nicht, ob es mittlerweile Link
Linkvorschauer kann
Also kann ich nur empfehlen
FFZ, beste
Ah, ja, ja
Der Tainzer ist am Start
Drei Monate, huge sub
Sehr nice, sehr nice
So, ich muss jetzt erstmal Steamlabs aufmachen
Nicht Steamlabs
Streamlabs muss ich aufmachen
Ich sehe da nichts verblendet
Übrigens, ich lade gerade ein Video hoch
Und ich habe es nicht verblendet
50 Minuten Modern Warfare Beta-Fazit
Äh
Steamlabs spinnt rum
Sagt die letzten, letzten Subs
Letzten Subs hat es vor drei Tagen gegeben
Das kann ja überhaupt nicht sein
Letzten zwei Subs gab es gerade eben
50 Minuten, ja, 50 Minuten
Das hat sich eigentlich ganz gut so ergeben
Weil, ähm
Ich habe schon X-Fanatics
Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Pog
Ähm, das hat sich eigentlich ganz gut ergeben
Weil ich hatte ja schon ein Beta-Fazit
Auch, aber ich habe es nicht verblendet
Ich habe es aufgenommen
Und, ähm, der andere Serial hat mich auf Twitter gefragt
Ob ich mit ihm was zusammen aufnehmen will
Da habe ich erstmal gesagt, nee, eigentlich keinen Bock
Äh, irgendwie nicht so
Nicht so Bock
Und ich habe schon lange mit anderen Leuten nichts mal aufgenommen
Und so
Und das sackt ein bisschen, ne
Und
Warum spackt mein Twitch auf der anderen Seite so?
Na gut
Und da haben wir es mal probiert
Dann haben wir es mal probiert zusammen was aufzunehmen
Und ich muss sagen, das Video ist halt viel besser geworden
Was ich solo auf, also was ich alleine aufgenommen habe
Deswegen habe ich das noch ein bisschen zusammengeschnitten
Gameplay dahinter
Und habe es dann auch bei mir hochgeladen
Weil es war ja eigentlich, war es gedacht für seinen Channel
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob den überhaupt noch jemand kennt
Der ist auch schon ein paar Jahre am Start
Aber war jetzt glaube ich die letzten Jahre nicht mehr so
Äh, dabei
Hast du das Video von Westersburg gesehen
Zu der Beat
Was?
Nee
Was die Xtreme Newcomer
Fighters
Was für ein Video
Achso, das habe ich gesehen
Ich habe Beat, äh, ich habe irgendwie Beat gelesen
Äh, das habe ich gesehen, ja
Ja, ich kann ihn da voll nachvollziehen
Warum er da keinen Bock drauf hat
Also für seinen Spielstil ist auch Modern Warfare
Eher nix, ja
Übrigens, ich habe vorhin bei mir auf dem Tablet mal kurz angehabt
Und geguckt, was es auf YouTube so gibt
Was ich mir echt gerne angucken würde, ist das Video
Das geht 35 Minuten
Ist ein Black Mesa Speedrun
Ähm, allerdings kein
Kein Bot
Kein Bot Speedrun
Sondern wirklich von Spiel an ein Spiel allerdings segmented
Ja, also nicht, nicht jetzt irgendwie komplett 31 Minuten am Stück gespielt
Und ich weiß, dass Half-Life, beziehungsweise generell Source
Source Speedruns sind immer extrem geil anzugucken
Deswegen würde ich mir das jetzt gerne mal zum Aufwachen angucken
Kann ich auch mal ein Brötchen futtern dabei
Und mal einen Tee trinken
Ich trinke ja keinen Kaffee
Ich bin ja mittlerweile komplett auf Tee
Äh, Transitioned
Und
Da kann ich mir das mal in Ruhe reinnehmen
Reinhauen jetzt
Und immer wenn es
Und jetzt dabei können wir
Können wir schwätzen
So wie wir das jeden Aufwachstree machen
Also gucken wir uns das mal an
Und danach gucken wir noch
Gucken wir noch ein paar andere Sachen
Und danach gucken wir hier noch ein bisschen irgendwie Tactical Knife
Oder irgendwelche Sachen
Ich habe halt übrigens noch mehr
Wir müssen uns das neue
Das neue Projekt von Kim.com angucken
Der hat irgendwas Neues
Ich weiß nicht, was er genau macht
Ähm
Kein Tass, aber segmented
Ja, richtig
Oh, Team DK
Twitch Prime
P-P-P-Prime
Okay, auf geht's
Gehen wir mal los
Hello and welcome to the Black Mesa
Äh, nein, okay
Ach, der fängt später an
Der fängt, der fängt schon an
Der fängt schon an zu runnen
Äh, der überspringt das Intro
Das ist natürlich eine gute Idee
Arriving
Sektor C Test Labs
Also, wenn ich mir andere Half-Life Spiele
Ich muss echt sagen
Ich bin begeistert
Wie schön sie
Wie schön sie die Original-Levels
Im Black Mesa nachgebaut haben
Ich hab's ja auch
Also, mein Let's Play
Na, wer sich erinnert
Vor vier Jahren oder so
Äh, ist ja mittlerweile fertig
War ich auch immer begeistert
Wie schön sie die Architektur
Vom Original hingekriegt haben
Das sieht echt cool aus
Ich denke mal
Also, die ersten fünf Minuten
Dürften von dem Speedrun
Jetzt nicht sonderlich speedy sein
Auch wenn es von speedy ist
Ähm, weil das Half-Life Intro
Halt immer recht lange dauert
Aber gucken wir mal
Oh, Mr. Freeman
Running late
Oder irgendwie sowas
Guten Morgen, Leute
Worum geht's in diesem Stream?
Wir gucken
Äh, im Prinzip reacten wir
Ich glaube, das ist das modernere Wort dafür
Nice
Wir gucken uns irgendwelches Zeug an
Schwätzen ein bisschen
Und wachen auf
Und dann, äh, schalte ich mein
50 Minuten Modern Warfare Beta-Fazit frei
Wenn es verarbeitet ist
Ich muss immer nebenbei gucken
Es braucht noch eine Stunde zum Hochladen
26% erst hochgeladen
Geht das überhaupt noch hoch?
Leute, ich muss das mal im Blick haben
Ob das überhaupt noch hochlädt
Ja, okay
Die Zeit ist gerade
Die Zeit hat sich gerade angepasst worden
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee
Nicht langsamer Upload
Ich hab den Upload gedrosselt auf 15 Mbit
Dass ich auf jeden Fall
Äh, lagfrei streamen kann
Also eigentlich
Upload ich nur langsamer
Damit ich streamen kann
Five-Hand-Move, ja
Okay, gucken wir mal
Running late
Nee
Ja, genau
Ich kann immer noch
Ähm
Ich kann immer noch den Text der Black Mesa-Bahn
Auswendig
Ähm
Und das meiste von den, ähm
Von, was die Wachen erzählen
Ist Wahnsinn
Ich hab das Game so oft durchgespielt
Weil er mir gerade Krach macht
Hat er mich gerade sehr laut genannt?
Hat er, hat er mich
Hat er gerade sehr laut gesagt?
Hey, Mr. Freeman
Dr. Freeman?
Source Speedruns sind einfach geil anzugucken
Why do we all have to wear these ridiculous ties?
Erstmal ins Game rein und direkt losgebunnyhoppe
Wow
Oh, jetzt kommen irgendwelche Prop-Glitches noch gleich an den Start
Achso, ist die Lautstärke eigentlich okay?
Warte mal kurz
Ich mach mal, wo wir schon gewesen sind
We all have to wear these ridiculous ties
Lautstärke ist okay, oder?
Und wir ticken leiser, ticken lauter oder ist gut so?
Ist gut
Also ich weiß nicht, wie, wie, wie Freeman jedes Mal late sein kann bei dem Speed
Übrigens, die Hammer
Au!
Das überlebt man?
Der muss sich gut die Levels gemerkt haben
There you are
Der glitscht sich jetzt irgendwo durch oder so
Nee, mehr Speed
I'm afraid we'll be deviating a bit from standard speed
A bit from standard analysis procedure today, Gordon
Yes, yes, but with good reason
Moin, peinlicher Affe
This is a rare opportunity for us
This is the purest sample
Ich glaub, das nervt jeden Half-Life-Speedrunner, dass man das nicht überspringen kann
Most unstable
Now, now, as long as we follow standard insertion procedures, everything will be fine
I don't know how you can say that
Although I will admit
That the aftermath of a Resonance Cascade scenario is extremely unlikely
I just don't feel welcome
Gordon doesn't need the hero in this
He's a highly trained professional
We've assured the Administrator that nothing will be the same
Man kann in Source, in der älteren Source-Version
Ich weiß nicht, ob es in neueren Source-Versionen geht
Gordon, we have a unique competition
Dann haut man den NPCs auf den Kopf
Und dann, dann, dann springen die zu ihrem nächsten Wegpunkt weiter
Habt ihr's gesehen?
Das geht in allen Source-Games
Man muss...
Testing, testing
What the fuck?
MonkaS
Testing
Everything seems to be in order
Noch ein Ticken laut, oder?
Oh, Gordon, your suit should keep you comfortable through all this
The specimen will be delivered to you in a few moments
Grafik sieht echt gut aus
Ja, Black Mesa sieht gut aus
Für ein 15 Jahre altes Game
That way we can bring the anti-mask spectrometer to 80%
Monka smoke time, klar angesagt
Alter
Das übertreibt mich
Was macht der da?
Glitscht er sich jetzt oben durch die Wand, oder was?
Ah ne, das ist einfach nur Show, weil er sonst nichts machen kann
Ich dachte, man kann sich da schon durchglitschen, aber ich glaube
Man kann sich da durchglitschen, es bringt bloß nix
Weil...
Weil die nächste Sequenz erst lädt, wenn das fertig ist
Gordon, wir können nicht präsentieren, wie lange die Systeme auf diesem Niveau funktionieren können
Gleich, Leute, MonkaSmoke
Bitte, arbeiten Sie so schnell wie Sie können
Die Überflusskapazität liegt bei 105%
Äh, es ist wahrscheinlich kein Problem
Aber ich zeige Ihnen eine kleine Bescheidenheit in...
Na, nein, es passt gut, wenn wir die Sequenz nachvollziehen
Wir haben gerade informiert, dass die Sequenz nachvollziehen wird
Der Speedrunner sitzt jetzt da
Wann geht's los? Wann geht's los? Wann geht's los?
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie es da weitergeht
Das ist ja noch Standard
So wie es jeder spielt, fast, fast
Also, außer das Rumjumpen
Man beachte, wir sind jetzt bei ungefähr
Sagen wir mal, naja, so 10% oder so von der...
Ne, Quickmuffs
Keine Ahnung, 15% oder so
Von der, von der Gesamtzeit
Wir sind erst beim Intro, das heißt, man kann sich vorstellen
Wie schnell das das nächste Mal geht
Das habe ich nie gecheckt, wo ich klein war
Die Sequenz gab es im originalen Half-Life auch
Da habe ich nie gecheckt, was diese Viecher wollen
Ich checke es übrigens bis heute noch nicht
Ich glaube, die feiern dann irgendwie, weil man sie rettet oder so
Storytechnisch, keine Ahnung
Aber who cares, Story
Okay, jetzt geht, jetzt will er Swimmen
Ach, da kann man rauf?
Irgendwie ist es übelst laut auf meinem Ohr
Sonst kriegen die NPCs erstmal wieder Dinge auf den Kopf gehauen
Dass sie schneller sind
Hast du schon mal einen PC2 Speedrun gesehen?
Nee
Mir fällt gerade etwas auf, Leute
Wisst ihr, was mir gerade auffällt?
Das sind die Typen aus Half-Life 2
Big Braintime
So, dann erst mal das Ding auf den Kopf hauen
Erstmal Anlauf nehmen.
Okay, was auch immer.
WTF?
The fuck?
Ich hab doch gesagt, jetzt geht's richtig los.
Dass da die Map überhaupt mit dem Laden nachkommt.
Also wie Gordon jemals late sein kann,
verstehe ich nicht.
Durch die Wand klitschen?
Oder WTF?
Tatsächlich durch die Wand klitschen.
Ja, Source Engines, Speedruns sind
immer geil anzusehen.
Habt ihr's gesehen?
So ist das Ganze nicht gedacht.
So hat sich das in G-Man nicht vorgestellt.
Dass Gordon im Bild springt,
wenn der Brechstange in der Hand entgegenkommt,
ihn keines Blickes würdigt
und an ihm vorbeirauscht.
Titanfall Speedrun.
Oh, ich glaub, die haben da so viel dran gemacht.
Keine Ahnung.
Das können wir uns...
Schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Schreibe ich mir mal auf Titanfall Speedrun.
Das ist eine richtig gute Idee, mal anzusehen.
WC2 Speedrun, Titanfall Speedrun.
Muss ich ja mal aufschreiben.
WC2.
Okay.
Aber das ist lustig, ey.
Oui!
Bye!
G-Man, piss dich, Alter!
Piss dich, G-Man.
Ich muss jetzt irgendwelche komischen Dinger aufschrauben.
Also ich muss jetzt...
Ich muss sagen, der muss die Levels echt gut kennen, der Typ.
Es läuft immer noch die Musik,
die normalerweise am Anfang läuft,
aber er ist schon durch das Level halb durch.
Da ist ein Luftschacht.
Ich dachte, man müsste jetzt diese komische Rampe runter.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Ach ja, doch, das hier ist das.
Ah, ich erinnere mich.
Jetzt muss man die Rampe runter.
Okay.
Easy.
Das haben mehrere gemacht.
Das kann sein, aber es ist auf jeden Fall segmented.
Ja, ist es, ist es.
Oh, RIP.
Gleich splattert das Viech, hä?
Ne, äh, ist.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was gerade passiert ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, das ist Blind Playthrough.
Der hat es vorher noch nie gespielt.
Offensichtlich.
Aber Source Speedruns sind echt immer geil.
Oder generell Half-Life Speedruns.
Kann man sich echt immer gut geben.
Das ist schon Office, oder?
Ich glaube, das ist schon Office-Komplex, wo er jetzt ist.
Da brauchst du normalerweise eine Stunde hin.
Normalerweise spielst du bis hier locker eine Stunde.
Au.
Okay.
Hast du schon die Half-Life Speedrun?
Ich sehe, eigentlich haben wir uns noch nicht angeguckt.
Was war denn das?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist noch ohne Xen.
Xen ist ja noch nicht fertig, offiziell.
Okay.
Oder kommt jetzt erst Office-Komplex?
Was?
Hä?
Ist das irgendein Lade?
Lade?
Was auch immer?
Klitsch?
What?
What the hell?
Was passiert gerade?
Klitscht das nicht durch die Wand, oder was?
What?
Das ist Big Brain Next Level.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was passiert, aber...
Bestimmt nicht einfach.
Okay, das heißt, ein bisschen Speed aufbauen.
Noch mal, okay.
Noch mal durch die Wand boosten, auf geht's.
Schreckt.
Alter, WTF?
Poggers.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Das ist aber echt krass, ey.
Da will ich nicht wissen, wie oft sie das gespielt haben, diesen Abschnitt, bis das funktioniert hat.
Die Musik ist immer noch vom Office-Komplex.
Jetzt kommt mir das Ding.
Jetzt kommt das Tentakel-Zeug.
Einfach noch 8 Leben übrig hat.
Ja, jetzt kommt das Tentakel-Zeug.
Das wird er wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie überspringen.
What?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Leute, wisst ihr was?
Ich muss mal kurz meine Bildchen ein bisschen kleiner machen, weil man sieht so wenig vom Bild.
So, perfekt.
Das muss ich mir gerade nochmal angucken.
Das habe ich nicht gecheckt.
Man kann da einfach reinspringen?
What?
Okay, was auch immer.
Das scheint zu funktionieren.
Das ist echt Big Brain Place.
Das Ding muss man normalerweise zusammenschieben.
Äh, nicht zusammenschieben.
Das Ding muss man normalerweise so eine Brücke drüber machen.
Und jetzt sind wir in On Rail?
Sind wir On Rail?
Ne, wir sind vor On Rail, oder?
Ja, wir sind vor On Rail.
Und jetzt
kletschen wir uns zu On Rail durch.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da passiert.
Jetzt sind wir
am Ende von On Rail?
Am Ende von On Rail?
Ne, noch?
Ne?
Äh.
Okay.
Ich glaube, wir sind tatsächlich irgendwo mitten.
Wir sind bei der Rakete in On Rail?
Ne, ich blick nicht mehr durch, wo wir gerade sind.
Das ist mir zu hoch.
Ah, ne, doch, das ist noch On Rail.
Das ist noch mitten in On Rail.
Ja, okay.
Das ist vor der Rakete noch.
Okay, jetzt sind wir erstmal wieder out of bounds.
Rausgeglitcht. Das ist Nine Head.
Big Brain IQ.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was gerade überhaupt passiert.
Jetzt ist er bei der Rakete gleich.
What the fuck, Alter.
Krasser Scheiß.
So, jetzt kommt er ins Außenareal gleich.
Ja? Ne. Ach, ne, hier.
Hier ist er noch.
Ja, genau, jetzt kommt er rechts zur Rakete.
Jetzt rechts ist irgendwo die Rakete.
Wenn ich das noch irgendwie richtig erkenne.
Alles bei der Geschwindigkeit.
Da blickst du wirklich nicht mehr richtig durch.
Ja, genau, jetzt ist er bei der Rakete.
Alter, ich brauche da 45 Minuten durch.
Also, ich muss zugeben.
Der ist deutlich besser ein Half-Life als ich.
Weil der sieht so easy aus, wie der was macht.
Also, was ist das hier? Umweltverschmutzung.
Anzeige ist raus.
So arme Pylonen, ja.
Genau, da ist nicht Anzeige raus, da ist Greta raus.
Okay, jetzt weiß ich nicht, wo er gerade...
Ah, jetzt ist er im Außenareal bei der Rakete.
Jetzt müsste er normalerweise die Rakete zünden.
Was er aber wahrscheinlich, so wie ich das hier sehe, nicht machen wird.
Sondern sich wieder durch die Wand klitscht.
Oder fast stirbt.
Im Boden stecken bleibt.
Ich glaube, im Boden stecken bleibt.
Und ohne die Raketen zu zünden, durch ist.
Auch gut. So kann man es auch machen.
Jetzt irgendwelche Speicher-Klitsch-Dinger wieder.
Ich kann mir das ja auch nur zusammen reiben.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was genau passiert.
Normalerweise...
Ist das jetzt nicht das hier, wo man durch die Wand fährt?
Nee, oder?
Okay, ich blick nicht mehr durch, wo er gerade ist.
Das ändert sich auch so schnell.
Ach jetzt ist er...
Oh Leute, da hatte ich...
Als ich klein war, hatte ich vor dieser Szene hier übelst Angst.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich das gespielt habe.
Das mit dem Fisch.
Da hatte ich übelst Monka-Est immer hier.
So jetzt gerade.
So jetzt, wo der Fisch rauskommt.
Da habe ich immer übel Schiss davor gehabt, wo ich klein war.
Also klein.
Wie alt war ich denn da? 14 oder so?
Schaust du Zoktoberfest?
In your face.
King Wall, ja das klingt...
Jetzt ist er bei den Assassins.
Kommt er jetzt zu den Assassins?
Das ist, das ist, wo die...
Wo die Stealth-Assassin-Dinger jetzt sind, ne?
Ja, ja, ja, genau.
Normalerweise muss man hier die Assassins bashen.
Und dann wird man gefangen genommen.
Hatte ich mal Promote?
Ah, jetzt weiß ich wieder, ja.
Jetzt, genau, jetzt wirst du gefangen genommen.
Ach, aber...
Man kann sich bewegen in dem Raum sogar noch.
Lustig.
Habe ich nie probiert.
Stirbt der jetzt?
Ne, okay, das ist komplett gescriptet, die sind unverwundbar.
Normalerweise spielst du 3-4 Stunden, bis du hier bist.
3-4 Stunden, wenn du schnell bist.
Bis hierhin jetzt.
Und das ist jetzt halt so der typische Fehler,
den alle Bösewichte machen.
Anstatt, den Held zu killen,
schmeißen sie ihn natürlich erstmal in eine Schrottpresse,
weil absolut big brain-Bösewichte immer...
Somehow hat er sich hier so versichert.
So Schrottpresse...
Ich glaub, das hat jeder beim ersten Anlauf verkackt,
als er das erstmal Uflife gespielt hat, die Schrottpresse.
Die Schrottpresse.
War das Absicht, dass er den Eimer runter...
Das war Absicht, dass er den Eimer runtergeschmissen hat.
Wahrscheinlich will er sich irgendwo hochboosten damit oder so.
What?
The fuck?
Hä?
Was zum Teufel? Geht ab!
Ich flieg nicht mehr durch, ja.
Aber das ist so geil anzugucken.
So, jetzt kommt normalerweise diese Parcoureinlage.
Ja, Pog like this ist das.
Ah, richtig.
Normalerweise muss man jetzt Parcour-Stells machen hier.
Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass er das nicht machen wird.
Die Half-Life sind ja keine Zombies.
Oh, weggesplattert.
Wie heißen die Dinger nochmal in Half-Life, diese Zombies?
Die heißen glaube ich nicht Zombie, ne?
Aber die Sounds von den Dingern immer.
So, jetzt kommt nochmal Schrottpresse.
Häcksel, Schrott und Dreck-Kram.
Nicht Headcrabs.
Die Dinger, wo die Headcrabs auf dem Kopf sitzen, die heißen die nochmal.
Heißen die vielleicht doch Zombies? Ich weiß nicht.
Heißen die echt Zombies? Okay.
Das haben sie richtig gut eklig hinbekommen.
Das sieht richtig nach Scheißwasser aus.
Richtig so hier nach Haufen.
Oh, Kiefkin, Rezap, Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön, Pog.
Alter, wie gut kennt der die Level eigentlich?
Nils, FPS, Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Okay, das ist nicht der Intended-Weg.
Alter.
Jodi, XD.
Das geht?
Ich dachte, man muss über den Zaun klettern und sich Elektro schocken lassen.
Ist da irgendwas der Intended-Weg? Ja, das gerade.
So, mal ab und zu ein paar Sekunden zwischendurch ist der Intended-Weg.
Oder das Intro so halbwegs.
Richtig Highspeed-Pepega hier unterwegs.
What?
Der müsste jetzt eigentlich ein paar Wissenschaftler retten, dass das funktioniert.
Okay.
Heiß.
Oh, mit der Waffe, jetzt geht's ab.
Da kannst du nicht übertriebenes...
Ja, das kenne ich. Da kannst du übertriebenes Speed zulegen.
Woah.
Er lässt das CSGO surfen, oder was?
Highspeed-Pepega unterwegs.
So, einfach mal überlebt, weil Wasser.
Das ist doch keine Surf-Map, Alter.
Wie oft er geblitzt wird.
Der hat schon Strafzettel-Flatrate.
Man kann da rauf?
Okay, was?
Also, ich bin echt beeindruckt von dem Speedrun.
Jetzt kommt es.
Das Granatending, der tritt natürlich nicht auf eine Mine.
Aha.
Okay.
Ja, Source-Speedruns sind immer geil.
Das stimmt.
Okay, der schießt sich jetzt quer über den Berg.
100 Pro.
Und kommt genau oben am Ausgang raus.
Ich sag's euch, warte mal ab.
Der schießt sich quer über den Berg, kommt genau oben an der...
What the fuck, Alter?
Da komme ich mir wieder...
Linkshändige mit zwei linken Händen...
Kack-Noob vor.
Wenn ich das sehe.
Dafür hast du zwei Jahre Netz...
Ja!
Na gut.
Mein Netzplay insgesamt ging sechs Stunden oder so.
Und der ist halt in 37 Minuten durch.
Und ich war schon relativ schnell.
Krasser Schiller.
Okay, jetzt...
Ich glaube, Lambda-Komplex dauert noch ein bisschen.
Jetzt kommt erst mal dieses ganze Zwischending dazwischen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man...
Wie man diesen Abschnitt in der Half-Life nennt.
Da, wo die Sniper und so oben am Fenster stehen.
Okay, hier oben...
Hier oben...
Hier oben sind eigentlich überall Sniper drin, die dich ownen.
Aber er ist zu schnell.
Ach, das ist...
Okay, jetzt kommt das Lagerhaus, wo man keine Minen triggern darf,
weil sonst das ganze Haus in die Luft fliegt.
Das muss er anscheinend halbwegs intended machen, so wie es aussieht.
Okay, das ist...
Das ist alles intended bis jetzt.
Alles intended.
Zwar...
Sag mal so, es ist...
Man geht normalerweise außen,
wo man sich nicht mehr verhalten kann.
Und oben drüber über den Fahrstuhl.
Aber das ist jetzt immerhin alles so gewesen, wie gedacht.
Wir sollten Portal-Speedruns schauen.
Ja, hab ich schon ein paar geguckt.
Die sind wirklich nice.
Wie lang ist denn ein Titanfall 2 Speedrun?
Einfach mal mit der Mini hier rumstelzen.
So lang.
So, hab mir jetzt das Game auf Steam gekauft.
Oh, jetzt wird wieder durch die Wand geklitscht, hä?
Wow!
Raketenfreeman!
Raketenfreeman, ja.
Na, 80 Minuten ist ein bisschen lang.
Krass.
Echt heftig.
Aber du hast das Geld auf jeden Fall gut investiert.
Das ist ein super Remake von Half-Life 1.
Echt, echt richtig gut.
Ich meine, mir persönlich gefällt Half-Life 1 immer noch besser,
weil es das erste Game war,
quasi, was ich richtig lange, viel gesuchtet, gespielt habe.
3D.
Wobei, stimmt gar nicht.
Erste 3D-Shooter, den ich richtig gut fand.
Den ich viel lang gesuchtet habe.
Aber für die heutige Zeit ist das Remake auf jeden Fall mehr zu empfehlen als das Original.
Der Typ geht mega ab, ey.
Ui!
Normalerweise, normalerweise, ne?
Normalerweise rennt hier so ein fettes Viech hinter dich her.
Ähm, so ein fettes Viech mit Flammenwerfern rennt hier normalerweise hinter dich her.
Und du musst hier die Mörser einstellen, um das damit zu killen.
Aber das macht er nicht.
Der jumpt einfach weiter.
Hehehehe.
Mirror's Edge World Record.
Ja, können wir machen.
Wie lange geht der?
Der geht nicht lang, oder?
Wie lang geht der?
Hast du mal einen Link?
Ah, der wird hier durchflutscht.
Keine halbe Stunde.
Das gucken wir uns an.
Ja, ja.
Die Mirror's Edge World Record gucken wir uns noch an.
Hast du mal einen Link?
Oh, hier sind, hier sind Haifische.
Ne, auch nicht Haifische.
Wie heißen diese Fische?
Diese komischen Half-Life-Fische drin.
Okay.
Okay, erst mal schön durch die Decke klitschen oder sowas.
Ja.
Äh.
Okay.
Okay, der ist jetzt einfach schon Lambda-mäßig drinne.
What?
Null.
Link im Discord.
Okay, danke schön.
Take.
Die sind von mir, die Immorts.
Noch mal schön durch die Wand klitschen, hä?
Hat's jetzt nicht geklappt, oder braucht der wirklich zwei Schuss?
Nee, der braucht mehr Schuss.
Das hat geklappt.
Ja, hab ich.
Plantera, der ist im Chat.
37 Minuten Mirror's Edge.
Krasser Scheiß, Alter.
Ich bin echt am Staunen.
Ich bin richtig am Staunen.
Der Speedrun ist wirklich cool.
Poggers Run ist das.
Autoscroller.
Moment.
Hat der gerade, hat der gerade das gesamte Level übersprungen?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Hat der gerade das gesamte Level übersprungen?
Das muss ich mir gerade noch mal angucken.
Hab gerade von dem Zocktoberfest das erste Mal gehört und dann festgestellt, dass ich in einer halben Stunde da bin.
Du meinst jetzt Location-mäßig?
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Hat der gerade das ganze Level übersprungen?
Poggers!
Ey, das ist ja richtig geil.
Der hat das ganze Level übersprungen.
Das dauert normalerweise eine Stunde.
Okay.
Bis man das hat.
Äh, Kalumina01, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Poggers.
Äh, ich muss noch kurz gucken, habe ich was übersehen?
Ähm.
Nope.
Execution, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Da wird das ganze Level übersprungen.
Ich bin echt schockiert.
Actual Big Brain Place hier.
Ist echt Raketen Freeman wieder angesagt.
Ja, wir haben gleich ein Jetpack verpassen können.
Wir müssen das doch mal hier kurz huldigen, wie schön das die Black Mesa Leute hingekriegt haben.
Guckt euch mal an, wie schön das Loch aussieht.
Jetzt nicht, nicht Leute, das, also ich mein, ne?
Jetzt keine anstößigen Dinger, bitteschön.
Ähm, wie schön sie das hier gemacht haben.
Ja, der Chat wieder, der Chat.
Der Chat, der Chat.
Ne, aber wie schön sie das hier reinge, reinge, äh.
Also es sieht richtig geschmolzen aus.
What?
Das geht?
Das wusste ich nicht, dass das geht.
Ernsthaft?
Das geht?
Man kann mit diesem Ding die Türen aufschießen?
Das ist wirklich Big Brain.
Der ganze Run ist einfach nur Big Brain.
What the fuck, ey.
Was sagst du, neuer Twitch-Rapper-UI?
Ich find's von den Farben nicht schön.
Deswegen FFZ installieren und einfach eigene Farben einstellen.
So, der Run ist vorbei, Clay.
Das ist, das ist der vorletzte Raum.
Wo er jetzt ist.
Der vorletzte Raum.
What?
Ah, Reset.
Reset, er steckt fest.
Okay.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was überhaupt passiert gerade.
Was passiert?
Was, was ist gerade los?
Okay, ich seh, der klitscht sich immer ein Stückchen weiter.
Wahrscheinlich ist er da.
Okay.
Ach, ich weiß, was passiert.
Ich hab nicht, ich glaub, ich weiß, was passiert.
Der klitscht sich in den, in den Trigger rein, wo es nach Xen geht.
Kann das sein?
In den Teleport-Trigger, wo es nach Xen geht?
Klitscht er sich rein?
Kann das sein?
Nee.
Okay, dann hab ich keine Ahnung.
Der hat einfach den Raum jetzt davor übersprungen.
Da ist sehr viel NPC und Dialoge in dem Raum vorher.
Der hat das Long-Jump-Modul doch gar nicht mitgenommen.
Okay, man kann 100% auf den Raum gehen.
100% in den Trigger vorher reinspringen.
100%!
Der macht nicht das ganze Level mit einem Lebenspunkt.
Das glaub ich nicht.
Was macht der da?
Auf die Cutscene warten.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das zu irgendwas dazugehört, dass er jetzt hier im Kreis Bunnyhoppt.
Der wartet einfach, bis der, bis der Fight losgeht.
Kreisel, genau.
Der kreiselt.
Kogas.
Oh, der macht doch den Fight.
Sonst würde er sich nicht die Leben und die Sachen holen.
Im originalen Half-Life konnte man da jetzt schon reinspringen und in den Xen-Trigger.
Oder Scan-Teleporter.
Alter, wie sie geschreckt werden.
Gut, der weiß halt überall, wo die Gegner spawnen.
Das ist der schwerste Fight im Game eigentlich.
Eigentlich, ja.
Für ihn halt nicht.
Für ihn ist das, für ihn ist das halt...
Was soll ich sagen?
Mit der Armbrust.
Ha, guck mal.
Die ganzen Mobs checken es nicht.
Normalerweise sagt der NPC jetzt, it's ready oder sowas.
Falls der NPC nicht geklitscht ist.
Alter.
Wahnsinn.
Fertig.
Wahnsinns-Run, ey.
Wahnsinns-Run.
Echt Next-Level-Shit.
Raketenfreeman am Start.
Eine Runde...
Klapper in Chat, ja.
Super Mario.
Super Star Wars Warplus.
Ach, das hat, glaub ich, eh schon jeder gesehen.
Können wir aber nachher gucken.
Was wir jetzt gucken.
Wir gucken uns den neuen...
Weiß nicht, ob der neu ist.
Der ist neu.
Mirror's Edge 80% World Record.
27...
Alter, 27 Minuten.
Sag mal, Westersburg, kann das sein, dass der einfach 10 Minuten schneller ist als du?
Der World Record, Dude.
Okay.
Von...
Ach so, Leute.
Jetzt erst mal hier gucken.
Ja, wir wollen jetzt nicht nur das Zeug angucken.
Den Black Mesa Xen-Trailer.
Ja, hab ich schon gesehen.
Guck mal.
Da ist der Black Mesa Xen-Trailer.
Können wir uns aber gleich schon mal angucken.
Also, hier.
Source Runs.
Okay, das ist Standard.
Von Speedy.
Haben wir uns gerade anguckt.
Der Xen-Trailer.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es den neuen gibt.
Welchen denn?
Game.com nicht vergessen.
Ja.
Max, wann kommen Frauen und Kinder eigentlich?
Ich hoffe nicht, dass Kinder in nächster Zeit kommen.
Ja.
Man darf nicht vergessen, das sind im Endeffekt alles Half-Life-Fans,
die den größten Teil ihrer Arbeit kostenlos zur Verfügung gestellt haben.
Gut, mittlerweile gibt es das auf Steam, aber Black Mesa konntest du komplett kostenlos,
das ist Source Engine, klar,
konntest du komplett kostenlos spielen, kannst du immer noch spielen.
Allerdings empfehle ich euch echt, die Steam-Version zu kaufen.
Erstens sind da, glaube ich, ein bisschen weniger Bugs drin
und die Leute zu unterstützen ist wirklich nicht verkehrt.
Und man darf nicht vergessen, das ist ein Fan-Projekt im Endeffekt.
Welche Farbe hat deine Katze?
Weiß, schwarz, orange.
Hat die Katze RGB, das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
RGB-Katze.
Das sieht übelst gut aus.
Ich freue mich schon, wenn das rauskommt.
Jetzt gibt es ja schon die Beta.
Alter, was ein dicker Sack.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie die...
Wie die es schaffen, aus der Source Engine so viel rauszuholen.
Sieht echt extrem gut aus.
Das ist die Katze.
Weiß, schwarz, orange, rot.
Verfolgst du auch Skyblivion?
Ne, was ist das?
Äh, was?
Source Engine hat nur Probleme mit Gesichtern.
Findest du?
Source Engine war eines der ersten Sachen, die richtig gute Gesichter hatten.
Apex ist auch Source, ja.
Titanfall ja auch.
Ist ja von den Geschichten.
Ist ja von den gleichen Typen.
Keine Katzen-Cam.
Ja, weil die zum größten Teil auf dem Kühlschrank in der hintersten Ecke liegt.
Da kann ich sie nicht filmen.
Okay, ähm...
Jetzt gucken wir uns an.
Any% World Record Mirror's Edge.
Ach doch, das habe ich irgendwo schon mal gesehen.
Clap King, Oblivion und Skyrim nachgebaut.
Das habe ich irgendwo schon mal ein Video zu gesehen.
Übrigens, ähm...
Wollen wir sagen, dass das erste Mirror's Edge einfach viel besser ist als das zweite Mirror's Edge.
Das zweite Mirror's Edge sackt des erstes richtig gut.
Warum kann man hier nichts machen?
Ich kann nichts Copy-Pasten.
Das triggert mich.
Ich muss Einser-Copy-Pasten können.
Okay, auf geht's.
Das ist auch...
Also, ich habe ja schon ein paar Mirror's Edge Speedruns gesehen,
aber das ist jedes Mal auch so immer absolut, äh, hier...
Mind-Blowing.
Ja, Mirror's Edge Speedruns.
Alter, was ist das für sexistisches Spiel hier?
Da werden Frauen geschubst.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Was ist da?
Anzeige.
Direkt.
Wa...
Vor allem, das Spiel sieht richtig gut aus, ja.
Also, also animiert, ja, aber ich finde, gerade was Mirror's Edge ausmacht, grafisch,
ist einmal, dass es so glänzend alles aussieht und die Farbkombinationen sind richtig nice.
Was zum...
Okay, ich kann zu Mirror's Edge nicht so viel sagen wie zu Half-Life.
Aber das Geile ist, bei Mirror's Edge Speedruns, man hat immer den Eindruck,
dass die Leute das so spielen, wie der Hersteller es gedacht hat.
Bloß halt noch viel krasser.
Alter, was ist mit der Wand los?
Da erkennst du überhaupt keinen Unterschied zum Rest.
Kannst ruhig was erzählen, ja, klar.
Ich denke einfach, dass genau so Mirror's Edge gespielt werden soll.
Da sind ja auch relativ wenige Out-of-Bounds-Klitsche und so dabei, oder?
Also jetzt nicht im Vergleich...
Mein Half-Life war die Hälfte Out-of-Bounds.
Also, ich gehe mal davon aus, das sieht einfach aus, ne?
Das Movement.
Aber ich glaube, es ist saumäßig schwer.
Er klitscht alle paar Sekunden mit dem Jump, ja.
Aber ich finde halt, das Geile ist, es ist im Prinzip...
Immer noch das Spiel in der korrekten Reihenfolge.
Was du halt bei Half-Life überhaupt nicht sagen kannst.
Das ist halt mega nice.
Du siehst halt einfach, dass die Leute extrem gut sind mittlerweile.
Und was bei Mirror's Edge cool ist, ist die Farbgebung.
Ich meine, keiner würde jemals ein Büro weiß-grün machen, ja.
Viele Speedrunner meinen, dass Mirror's Edge das schwerste Speedrun...
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Also, ich glaube, du musst da wirklich im...
Teilweise Millisekunden-Takt auf irgendwas achten.
Ich kann das jetzt selbst gar nicht...
So einschätzen, weil, wie gesagt, ich habe weder Mirror's Edge viel gespielt,
noch habe ich das jemals auch eine Ansatzweise versucht, das zu speedrunnen.
Aber ich finde, man sieht es auch als Außenstehender schon ein bisschen.
Okay, das ist jetzt so definitiv nicht gedacht.
Das ist jetzt so halb out of bounds geklitsche.
Aber es ist auch übelst nice anzugucken.
Wie wird Best Possible Time bestimmt?
Naja, alle Segmente, also alle Bestzeiten in den jeweiligen Abschnitten zusammengerechnet.
Also alle Bestzeiten der unterschiedlichen Abschnitte zusammengerechnet
ist dann Possible Best Time, würde ich sagen.
Für ihn halt.
Mausrad-Jump.
Ah.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie mit Lucio in Overwatch.
Da hast du auch Mausrad gejumpt.
Für bessere Walljumps.
Erstmal schön die Tür aufgekickt.
Zeigt mir mal ein.
Ich stelle mir das gerade so vor.
Stellt euch mal vor, ne?
Ihr steht im Gang.
Es kommen drei Leute aus dem Fahrstuhl raus.
Und das erste, was du machst, ist erstmal Anlauf nehmen.
Und dann kommst du raus.
Beine hochziehen bis zum Gesicht und über die drüber jumpen und in den Fahrstuhl rein, ey.
Das sieht, falls gut animiert ist, hier so natürlich aus.
Aber stellt euch das mal in echt vor.
Okay, das ist jetzt auf jeden Fall irgendein Out of Bounds-Gedingse.
Das ist einer der Gründe, warum Konsolen World Record 43 genug ist.
Ah, okay.
Ja, Mausrad-Jump, das Beste.
Sag mal, hier solltest du eigentlich gar nicht runterkommen, ne?
Wenn du den Boden berührst, ist wahrscheinlich Death Trigger.
Und hier darfst du eigentlich gar nicht runterkommen.
Und hier darfst du eigentlich gar nicht runterkommen, ne?
Normalerweise.
Okay, das ist jetzt so auf jeden Fall nicht gedacht.
Die Animationen sind echt nice in dem Game.
Also gut, das war jetzt ein Ladebildschirm.
Aber die Animationen in Mirror's Edge sind wirklich echt cool.
Es gibt...
Ich hab mal...
Ich hab in einem Video mal gesehen, Mirror's Edge, wo sie das Ganze aus der...
Also nicht aus der Ego-Perspektive gemacht haben, sondern die Kamera verschoben haben.
Also Faith ist nicht wirklich...
Ähm...
Anatomie-technisch menschlich aufgebaut.
Die sieht ziemlich kaputt aus, wenn man das aus Third-Person-Sicht anguckt.
Also Faith ist wirklich...
Grip.
Aus Third-Person-Sicht.
Warte mal, das müssen wir uns mal kurz zwischendurch angucken.
Das ist echt lustig.
Ähm...
Ne?
Das ist alles nicht das Video, was ich meine.
Egal, guck mal, das gucken wir mal nachher.
Das sieht aus Third-Person-Teilweise übel aus.
Das sieht kaputt aus.
Die Beine klitschen rum und...
Also, das wäre auf jeden Fall Grip.
Also, ich finde, was Mirror's Edge echt ein bisschen ausmacht, ist die Farbgebung.
Gut, ich meine, ich glaube, der hat hier auch sein Gamma extrem hochgestellt, weil so weiß ist das normalerweise nicht.
Wahrscheinlich will er einfach mehr FPS, oder?
Oder was ist das, Puck?
Warum ist das so?
Warum sieht das grafisch nicht ganz so gut aus?
Das ist Standard-Gamma.
Echt, sieht das echt so übertrieben...
Sah das so übertrieben erleuchtet aus?
Okay, was...
The fuck?
Okay, da können sich Raketen-Freemen noch was abgucken jetzt.
Der nutzt ja Glitcher aus, ja, natürlich.
Bei dem Trick habe ich mich bei dir auch schon gewundert, ja.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, wie geil das ist, 1.800 PSFPS zu streamen?
Jetzt sieht es nämlich bei euch im Stream genauso gut aus wie bei mir im Video.
Das ist huge Puck.
Habe ich übrigens auf höchste Auflösung eigentlich?
Ah ja, habe ich.
Erstmal...
Erstmal komplett vorbei.
Aber das Coole an Mirror's Edge ist wirklich, dass es...
Im Prinzip machen die Out-of-Bounds-Sachen aus, wo...
Dass es im Prinzip vom Ablauf her ziemlich ähnlich zu dem ist, wie es halt sich der Hersteller gedacht hat.
Nur halt zig geile Tricks dabei.
27P in 2019.
So komme ich immer zur Arbeit.
Ja, so slide ich übermorgen in die U-Bahn-Treppe.
Und ich nehme auch nicht den Fahrstuhl, sondern kletter erst mal das Regenrohr hoch.
Das mit dem 90 Grad drehen macht man, damit man immer auf Höchstgeschwindigkeit kommt.
Ja, das weiß ich noch.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Also, nicht vom Spielen, sondern vom Erzählen.
PC Lustig will in FaceDM sliden.
Na dann, GLHF.
Wie lange der gebraucht hat, bis der Run perfekt ist?
Wahrscheinlich hunderte Versuche.
Weißt du das, Westerosburg?
Wie lange der da...
Wie lange der da schon spielt?
Der spielt doch bestimmt schon jahrelang, oder?
Oder zumindest hat er einige hundert Runs drin.
Ja.
Hunderttausende Versuche.
Mehrere, ja.
Dreitausend plus Playtime.
Okay, jetzt klitscht es halt ein bisschen rum, weil man nicht da sein sollte.
Was hältst du vom Studium Wirtschaftsinformatik?
Das ist was du mal willst.
Da kann ich jetzt nichts Negatives dazu sagen, oder was Gutes.
Also, wenn du denkst, dass es was für dich ist, dann ist es wahrscheinlich das Richtige.
Mich kannst du mit BWL-Zeugs halt jagen, ne?
War das Absicht?
Nee, oder?
Ah, das war keine Absicht, okay.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt, man könnte jetzt nochmal so 15 Sekunden locker sparen.
Kannst du nachher Hitman?
Weiß ich nicht.
Mal gucken.
Denkst du, es macht Sinn, auch Kobol zu lernen?
Ah, eher weniger.
Es sei denn, du bist irgendwo, die wirklich Kobol-Leute brauchen und da gibt es fette Kohle, ja, vielleicht.
Aber eher nicht.
Ich finde es geil, wie die Voice-Samples oder die Sounds gar nicht nachkommen, ja.
Vom Kick dann zum Rollen.
Und so, das passt überhaupt nicht, dann...
Da ist noch Luft nach oben, 21 Minuten segmented.
Oh, nice.
Ja, klar!
No second plan.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Sickly Wig überhaupt noch streamt.
Oder ob da noch Mario spielt, ich glaube nicht mehr.
Tut der?
Das Mal, wo ich geguckt habe, hat der RuneScape oder, ne, ne, Dings, irgendwie sowas gespielt.
Ich meine, da musst du schon lange üben, dass du die ganzen Level so auswendig kennst, dass du...
dass du dann auch die perfekten Movement, äh, Dinger am Start hast.
Weil da soll man sehr wahrscheinlich nicht hoch, planmäßig.
Level auswendig kennen ist einfach Trick-Situation...
Wow!
Ah, okay, das war auch nicht gewollt, so.
Ja, wenn dich BWL interessiert, reicht's, dann ist Wirtschafts...
Also, wenn dich ein bisschen IT interessiert und BWL, dann ist Wirtschaftsinformatik auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Ich kann's mit BWL-Zeug jagen, ja.
Ach doch, Checkpoint mit R.
Ah, ich sehe hier, wir haben hier die Pros im Chat.
Ich finde immer, man erkennt immer ein bisschen, wenn er da lang geht, wo er nicht lang gehen sollte,
erstens, weil, dass du keine Farben hast, weil Mirror's Edge hat ja immer dort Farben, wo es lang geht,
ähm, sondern, dass die Texturen richtig scheiße sind.
Wenn die Texturen richtig scheiße sind, dann weißt du, das ist meistens ein Weg, wo du nicht lang solltest.
Hat Mirror's Edge normalerweise nicht Musik?
Die haben doch, die haben doch einen richtig coolen Soundtrack, den hat er ausgeschaltet, oder?
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich kann der Soundtrack noch so gut sein.
Ähm, wenn du das so lange spielst, geht's dir irgendwann auf den Sack.
Autsch.
Sipp.
Allerdings war Absicht, ne?
Auch Fail, okay.
Gartentour, nee.
Ich habe eigentlich keine Ahnung von der Mirror's Edge-Story, ich weiß nur, dass sie irgendwie ihre Schwester retten will.
Ja, weiß ich dazu nicht.
Ich glaube, reicht auch, mehr muss man dazu glauben, aber das wisst ihr.
Kann man nach so vielen Fails noch von einem guten Speedrun sprechen?
Naja, es ist ein Weltrekord.
Also, der ist schon ziemlich gut.
Aber man sieht auch daran, dass es halt viel schneller ginge.
Aber das Spiel besteht anscheinend aus so vielen Tricks, die du perfekt machen musst, dass es wohl sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, dass jemand einen richtig perfekten Run irgendwie fünf, dreißig Minuten oder so am Stück hinlegt.
Vielleicht, ja klar, als TAS kannst du das schon machen, aber ich gucke mir, ganz ehrlich, TAS-Sachen gucke ich mir ab und zu mal an, aber ich finde das nicht so reizvoll.
Ich finde es viel cooler, wenn ich weiß, dass ich das nicht so gut mache.
Danach gucken wir noch ein Modern Warfare 2 Video von Fortunaid wieder.
Das gucke ich immer gerne.
Das erinnert mich jetzt an Half-Life.
Luftschacht-Gestälze.
Ich finde es geil, wie sie die Türen immer aufkickt.
Übrigens, dieser Sound, haben die den Sound geklaut in Modern Warfare?
Hört euch das mal an.
Hä?
Original Modern Warfare Tür-Sound.
Wolltest du auch noch Kim.com?
Ja, können wir auch machen.
Nein, nicht wirklich Sound geklaut.
Quatsch.
Hört sich aber ähnlich an, wie die Modern Warfare Tür aufmacht-Sounds.
Du wirst jetzt der neue Unge für Speedruns.
Mensch, merke mal, wie viele Views Unge macht.
Easy.
React dich einfach ein bisschen und gut ist.
Wobei man sagen muss, Reacten ohne Webcam ist schwierig.
Okay, hier oben sollte man auf jeden Fall nicht lang zu der...
Zeit.
Zumindest ist der Boden übelst geklitscht.
Face-Reveal.
Doch, alles intended, okay.
Ich mache mir einfach so eine Plastiktüte oder eine Papiertüte.
Schneide zwei Löcher rein und drücke vorne einen Keks drauf und ziehe es mir über den Kopf.
Aber dann kann man sich das mit der Facecam auch sparen.
Weil dann sieht man ja nicht, wie man reactet.
Oder ich werde einfach hauptberuflicher React-Streamer.
Wenn ich dann irgendwann, keine Ahnung, 15.000 Subs habe oder so.
Okay.
Dann ist mir nämlich auch egal, ob mich die Leute erkennen oder nicht.
Da gehe ich nämlich einfach nicht mal aus dem Haus, weil da habe ich genug Geld.
Mache einfach den ganzen Tag Reaction.
Dude.
OKS, was jetzt?
Tactical Nuke Incoming.
Krass.
Also die Abläufe sind schon ziemlich optimiert von dem.
Das ist zwar der Weg, den man laufen soll, allerdings, dass das so smooth alles funktioniert.
Ja, ich glaube, man kann es auch so machen.
Man kann sie aus jeder Höhe abrollen, wenn man es richtig macht.
Oder aus fast jeder Höhe, ne?
Ich glaube, da war was.
Oder zumindest deutlich höher, als es gedacht ist.
Danach mache ich richtig genau, erharrn.
Danach mache ich Reactions zu meinen Reacts.
Das ist Next Level.
Das ist dann Max Reacted zu Old Videos.
Dann reacte ich dann zu meinen Videos.
Und irgendwann, wenn ich lang genug reactet habe, sind meine alten Videos auch schon Reaction-Videos.
Okay, jetzt ist der Run fast fertig.
Fertig?
Ja.
Es geht langsam aufs Ende von dem Game zu.
Wobei, die größte React-Inception, die ich bisher gesehen habe, war immer noch, wo...
Warte mal, wer hat da auf wen?
InScope hat auf Unge reactet, der auf MontanaBlack reactet hat.
Das war echt komplett React-Inception.
Super Content.
Ja, anscheinend schon.
Das gucken sich ja hunderttausende Leute an.
Ich persönlich verstehe auch nicht so genau, warum, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall Content, den Leute sehen wollen.
Und außerdem ist er schnell produziert.
Mir kann keiner erzählen, dass Reaction-Content wahnsinnig aufwendig zu produzieren wäre.
Oh, hier solltest du auf jeden Fall nicht sein, so eine Kack-Textur, wie die Autos haben.
Aber zumindest ist der Boden fest.
Okay, oder auch nicht.
Das war jetzt aber Absicht, ne?
Das ist jetzt das, was er lädt, das an einer anderen Stelle wieder lädt.
Au.
Oh, voll in...
Wobei, jetzt kloppen sich ja zwei Grills.
316 in your face.
Ach du Scheiße, Patrick, das ist echt ein Ding.
Das ist ja quasi Penta-Reaction.
Moin, Tufu.
Die Fahrstuhlmusik, ja.
Frag mich nicht, warum.
Hat jetzt eigentlich überhaupt nichts damit zu tun.
Wo bloß die Speedrunner, ja.
Half-Life-Speedrunner, Mirror's Edge-Speedrunner, all andere Speedrunner.
Mario-Speedrunner.
Zeller-Speedrunner.
Alles, alles gespeedrunnt.
Ich wechsel nur immer häufig meinen Game-Attack, dass es nicht so auffällt, dass ich das alles selbst bin.
Das wäre sonst zu auffällig.
Ah, dann würden mich die Leute wieder flayen.
Max, no life.
Erst zwölf Stunden Mirror's Edge, dann zwölf Stunden Half-Life, dann zwölf Stunden Mario, dann zwölf Stunden Zeller.
Alles an einem Tag.
Parallel auf mehreren Rechnern.
Deswegen habe ich da überall einen anderen Game-Attack für.
So sieht's aus, ne?
Ich meine, man muss, manchmal muss man, muss halt man auch mal da durch, ja.
Daniel Lull.
Stufe 1, drei Monate.
Poggers.
300 Views.
Lull.
Ja, so nice.
Schön, dass ihr alle da seid.
Ich hab ein Video, ja, ja, ich hab ein Video zu Mirror's Edge gemacht.
Allerdings hat er der Westhausburg gespielt, ne, nicht ich.
Emperor V1, Twitch Prime.
Einen schönen Pog.
Jetzt ist es an der Zeit, mit Emperor V2 auch noch einen normalen Sub zu machen und dann mit V3 einen Tier-2-Sub und mit V4 einen Tier-3-Sub.
Ich blick's selbst nicht mehr durch, was ich gerade erzähle.
Ach, jetzt ist dieses komische, ja, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, bei dem, bei dem Video, was wir zusammen gemacht haben hier.
Habe ich euch eigentlich heute schon mal erzählt, was man mit Amazon Prime und Twitch Prime für tolle Sachen anstellen kann?
Ja, letztes Level.
Ich finde die Farbgebung, ohne Scheiß, die Farbgebung ist in Mirror's Edge wirklich, äh, richtig, richtig, richtig gut gemacht.
Wow, Alter.
No second plan, Stufe 1, Poggers, dankeschön.
Max FPS abend, echt, sowas ist ein Ding.
Ich würd mir, ich würd mir meine Videos nicht angucken.
Also nicht fünf am Stück abends mit Leuten zusammen.
Das wär mir zu cringe.
Ich bin nicht der Einzige.
Also ich hab schon ein paar Comments gehabt, wo Leute gesagt haben, sie gucken sich die Videos immer zusammen machen und so.
Richtig cool.
So, jetzt kommt Final Boss, der zwei Sekunden dauert.
Ja, was kann man denn nun mit Amazon Prime machen?
Das verrate ich euch nicht, weil, wenn ihr es rausfindet, bekommt ihr einen Sub.
Gratis.
Darüber springt man den Boss komplett.
Ja, das Heli-Ding halt.
Ist ja nicht wirklich so.
Ist ja nicht wirklich ein Boss.
Also farblich haben sie das echt schick gemacht, das erste Mirror's Edge, kann man nix sagen.
Never Lucky, Twitch Prime, dankeschön, Poggers.
So, jetzt kommt der Heli-Stelz, ne?
Oder muss man, ne, ne, jetzt muss man durch den Serverraum.
Oder ist man durch den Serverraum schon durch?
Ne, jetzt kommt der Serverraum.
RTXAI, what?
So, soll ich gleich mal gucken.
Was, in zwölf Monaten nur ein Sub?
Was ist das für ein Skammas?
So, RIP.
Fertig, Run durch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wann stoppt der Run?
Jetzt schon oder erst, wenn irgendwie die nächste Szene anfängt?
Ab der Cutscene, okay.
Ach ne, das ist ja die Schwester.
Hab ich ja ganz vergessen.
Ja, das ist ein nices Game.
Ein sehr nices Game.
Hier noch was Lustiges für zwischendurch.
Ist das Kim.com?
Ach das, ne, das kenn ich schon.
Ähm.
Ich hab noch was zu Mirror's Edge geschickt, das sind nur 30 Sekunden, können wir uns noch kurz angucken.
Bist du jetzt Saarlander, ne?
Ist das Italienisch?
Ne, Spanisch?
Alter, was ist mit dem los?
Was passiert da gerade?
Easy.
It's easy.
Mach ich auch immer so.
So, Sebaru, hast du das Video mal für das neue, das neue Kim.com?
Kim.com Projekt, was wir uns angucken wollten.
Wir gucken uns jetzt noch eine Runde Tactical Knife Modern Warfare an.
Hab ich mir auch heute Morgen schon auf dem Tablet rausgesucht, das wollte ich mir auch mal angucken.
Haha, das war, das war so OP Shit.
Das war so OP Shit, Alter.
MLC legit.
Marathon Lightweight Commando.
Einmal Sebastian, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Das ist so OP gewesen, der Kram, Alter.
Alter, was ist mit den Gegnern los?
Wow, that was nasty.
What?
I'm just gonna lag out. Like, are you dead serious?
Oh, fuck.
Tja, da würde ich sagen, da ist der Host geragequittet, hä?
Da ist der Host geragequittet.
Das konnte dir ja in diesen ollen Lobbys noch passieren.
Das Video ist nicht von, das Video ist nicht alt, das Video ist von Ende 2018.
Ich mein, in Modern Warfare 2 war die Nuke zu einfach.
Ne?
Muss ich jetzt mal sagen.
In Modern Warfare 2 war die Nuke zu einfach.
Du hast in der Regel gemacht, Harrier, Chopper, Gunner, Nuke.
Das war, das war im Prinzip zu einfach.
Das hast du auch daran gesehen, was, dass die Leute irgendwelche Penta-Nukes oder sowas gemacht haben.
Aber, im aktuellen Modern Warfare ist die Nuke, so wie es jetzt ist, außer mal Ground War, schöne Klitsch-Spots auf dem Dach, nahezu unmöglich, wenn du gegen gleich gute Gegner gematcht wirst.
Das geht einfach nicht.
Du musst so krass dich anstrengen, dass du überhaupt mal irgendwie einen 25 Kill...
Ich hab einen Gameplay noch übrig, irgendwie 25, 4 oder sowas.
Und Leute, ich hab so massiv geschwitzt, bis ich meinen Chopper-Gunner hatte.
Das war nicht normal.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob mein Modern Warfare Video schon verarbeitet ist.
Ne, natürlich nicht.
Damals haben Leute nicht so krass getryhardet.
Ne, das liegt...
Auch, auch, ja, es gab damals richtig viele schlechte Leute, das ist heute weniger.
Aber, du hattest halt auch wirklich so Up-and-Down-Lobbys.
Du hattest richtig gute Lobbys, da war es sauschwer, was hinzukriegen.
Und du hattest Lobbys, wo wirklich nur Leute mit...
Irgendwie...
Keine Ahnung, mit...
Mit dem Fuß gespielt haben, oder so.
Saugst du noch Battlefield ab und zu mal ein paar ältere, aber das aktuelle Battlefield gefällt mir halt überhaupt nicht.
Und das Battlefield 1 war auch schon nicht so meins.
Naja, es ist erlaubt, dass er sich umdreht.
Es ist erlaubt, dass der Gegner sich umdreht, also komm.
Es ist nicht fair, Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Also, ja, es ist fair, aber es ist für alle...
Es macht für alle keinen Spaß, das ist ja das Problem da dran.
In Ranked, okay.
In Ranked, vollkommen in Ordnung.
In Ranked muss es sogar so sein.
Aber in Ranked hast du ja auch nen Rank dran stehen.
Wenn du nen Rank dran stehen hast, dann kannst du dir nicht auf deine KD und deine Killstreaks...
...einen abrubbeln, sondern kannst sagen, hey, guck mal, ich bin Grandmaster 4200.
Das ist dann cool.
Aber im Quickplay ist das...
...hat es überhaupt keine Daseinsberechtigung, weil Quickplay definiert sich in Content nur durch KD und ordentliches Killstreak-Gepäsche.
Vollkommen egal, ob man nächste Lobby wieder richtig auf die Fresse kriegt.
Aber es ist sowas, was ich da so...
...jede dritte, vierte Lobby dabei ist, wo man halt ordentlich was ab...
...wo man ordentlich abgehen kann.
Es macht keiner Seite Spaß, so wirklich.
Moin, Tylo.
War das gerade Controller?
Hat der gerade seinen Controller in die Ecke geschmissen?
Hört mal.
Ich habe nur...
Echt?
Okay, Leute, also meine Stimme kann...
...meine Stimme kann oder kann nicht ein bisschen anders klingen.
Ich musste neue Astros kaufen.
Eigentlich musste ich sie nicht kaufen.
Ich musste sie nicht eigentlich kaufen, weil meine anderen Astros noch unter Warrantie waren.
Ach nee, das war sein Headset, das war nicht der Controller.
Ja, also, wenn ihr euch fragt, wie sie gebrochen sind...
...ich habe sie tatsächlich auf den Boden geschlagen.
Und eines der Rage Clips, die ihr gesehen habt...
Ein kleines Auxilier-Kabel wurde tatsächlich getankt und dann einfach in das Ding gestockt.
Also ist es komplett gebrochen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich jemals mehr Glück gehabt hätte.
Weil ich hätte noch einmal $250 auf ein Paar Astros bezahlen müssen müssen.
Aber wirklich nur einen Tag.
Einen Tag.
Der Kerl hat mich gesehen.
Oh mein Gott.
Ich habe mich gerade verletzt.
Okay, lasst uns das machen.
Könnte das bitte das erste Spiel sein?
Mit dem neuen Headset.
Ja, fang mich hier wieder an.
Bisschen durchgeskippt.
Auf Wasteland stelle ich es mir schwierig vor.
Wobei halt Wasteland für Harrier das beste ist.
Mal gucken, ob er die Nuke schafft.
Ja, könnte sein.
Noch eine Minute Zeit.
Könnte sein.
Aber daran sieht man halt, dass Nuke zu einfach ist.
Welches der drei hast du gesehen?
Fuck, ich habe schon zugemacht.
Das mittellange habe ich irgendwie durchgeskippt.
Das eine war irgendwie so ein Interview.
Und das andere war
irgendwie auch so ein komisches, wo ich keine Ahnung habe,
was man sich da angucken sollte.
Oder meinst du, ich soll mir mal das 30 Sekunden Werbevideo angucken?
Aber es ist halt relativ easy. Hat man doch jetzt gesehen.
Der macht einfach mit dem
Techknife macht er einfach 7 Kills.
Harrier, Choppergunner, Nuke.
Das war unterm Strich, muss man sagen,
war das in Modern Warfare 2
schon zu einfach.
Hey Max, kannst du mir
vielleicht meinen Code angucken und mir sagen,
ob es laserlich oder Spaghetti ist? Klar, welche Sprache denn?
Ja, schick mal Pastebin oder so her.
Können wir uns angucken.
Ja, schick mal Pastebin.
Stimmt, und außerdem hat Nuke das Match beendet.
Everyone's got Painkiller, dude.
Oh my gosh, yo.
Painkiller galore.
Die halten aber was aus, ey.
God bless, bro.
That literally took so long. I know I only got 7 kills
with a knife this time around, but dude,
if you guys couldn't already tell by all the
rages I put in the beginning,
it's pain for me. Anyways, I hope
you guys did enjoy the video, did enjoy
the rages, cause there sure was a lot.
You guys are new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe, we are on the road to 100k.
Drop a like on the video, let's try and break
a thousand likes.
Appreciate that so much, guys.
Have a great day.
Oh, Unity, Tommy, zu Unity
Code kann ich mir nicht sagen. Ich kann mir zwar den
C-Sharp Code angucken, aber das ist ja relativ umfangreich.
Das können wir jetzt nicht im Stream machen.
Was haben wir ansonsten noch hier gerade?
Oh, ja! Nice!
Das gucken wir nochmal. Das ist auch
ein Klassiker.
Das ist auch ein
Wobei, nee, ist ein anderes Video, als ich gedacht
hab. Oh, das geht zu laut.
Sandy Ravaged.
Damals wollte jeder Videos...
Damals wollte
jeder
so abgehen wie Sandy Ravaged. Und was ich auch
damals nicht gecheckt habe, ist halt
ähm
Mega Uploads.
Was ich damals auch nicht
gecheckt habe, ähm
ist, dass
das ja auch nur ein kleiner Ausschnitt ist.
Wisst ihr?
Ich dachte immer, ich weiß nicht, wie
es euch da geht, ähm
Ich dachte
immer, da geht jedes Game so ab.
Und ich hab's nie gecheckt, dass es im Prinzip
einfach nur halt ein Ausschnitt
ist von den Games, wo es halt richtig gut gelaufen
ist. Das hab ich erst gecheckt, nachdem ich
selbst Videos gemacht hab, dass man
einfach nur die Videos eben hochlebt, die was taugen,
ja?
Habt ihr gehört? T-T-Tactical Header!
Bambi! Tactical Header!
Tango Sucker!
Die Modern Warfare 2 Sounds waren auch
am besten.
Was hältst du vom neuen Borderlands? Hab ich nicht gespielt, keine Ahnung.
Jetzt will er's wissen.
Das war das auch, was irgendwie die Sandy Ravaged
Videos ausgezeichnet hat.
Ah, der haut schon, der haut schon
echt gut rein, ne?
Der haut schon echt gut rein.
Proggers.
Vor allem
fällt euch mal auf, dass die Leute
damals auch noch zu dumm waren,
irgendwie den Launcher einzupacken oder so.
Die haben
alle die Killstreaks nicht abgeschossen.
Oder?
Nein, doch nicht.
Heutzutage bist du nicht mal eine Sekunde in der Lunge.
Ey, wisst ihr, wie schlimm das
ist in Ground War, in Modern Warfare?
Ich lade ja gerade ein Video
hoch und
da ist ein Ground War Gameplay dabei, wo ich dann auch
nen VTOL und
nen
Payflow und so am Start habe.
Die machen jeweils irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
zwei Kills, dann sind sie runtergegeiert.
Hier, Double Nuke.
Double oder Triple Nuke gibt das
dieses Video. Eher Double Nuke.
Ich meine, so wie der spielt,
es ist übelst glücklich, dass der nicht öfter
stirbt. Darf man auch nicht vergessen.
Wo man wieder sieht, es sind halt einfach nur die besten Runden.
Teilweise rennt er halt
übelst los und wird nicht gehittet.
Und außerdem
war in Modern Warfare 2 alles irgendwie
OP und konnte dich extrem schnell killen.
Wie war das?
Farmas rote Tigerstreifen beste?
Oder war das Black Ops?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr.
Wo jeder gesagt hat, Alter, Elotrix
ist Fake. Farmas rote Tigerstreifen.
Wo Farmas rote Tigerstreifen
quasi für einen Spieler reserviert war.
Weil manche Leute irgendwie ein bisschen beschränkt waren.
Keine Ahnung.
Die Musik passt da auch richtig geil dazu.
Na, gibt es doch ne Triple?
Gibt das doch ne Triple Nuke?
Oh, der ist okay.
Der musste eh sterben.
Warum darf der eigentlich Metallica Musik hochladen
und dafür nicht geblockt?
Haben die das
approved?
Metallica wird nicht gesperrt.
Klar wird Metallica gesperrt.
Ich hatte auch mal Metallica in einem Video, das war sofort weg.
Das ist gar kein...
Kann das sein, dass das
ein Metallica Cover ist?
Der Anfang hat sich
sehr Metallica-mäßig angehört, ja.
Ja, das ist
ne Metallica
Cover, so ein Best-of
Cover.
Jetzt werden sie wieder geschreckt.
Drei Stück bis zur Nuke.
Richtig nices Gameplay.
Der hat halt wahrscheinlich
wieder Side-Release
gespielt und durchgesuchtet zur damaligen
Zeit für dieses eine nice Gameplay.
Ich weiß, er hat viele nice Gameplays gehabt.
Aber das ist schon eines der besten.
Es ist...
Der Typ hat so krasses...
Oh ne, der stirbt jetzt. Er stirbt jetzt.
Es war klar.
Der Typ.
Der ist jetzt
krasser Rapper. Der hier.
Das Angry German Kid.
Der ist jetzt krasser Hip-Hop-Typ.
Dude.
Der hat nen eigenen Channel auf Youtube.
Ja, guck mal.
Ich war... Oh, wie hieß denn der Channel
nochmal hier? Angry...
Hercules Beats. Genau.
Ja. Da ist er doch.
Das ist er.
Das ist er. Also, der hat... Der ist mit
mittlerweile auf Youtube am Start.
Es ist eh sowas.
Hätte es damals Youtube gegeben
schon, hätte der mehrere
Millionen... Oder umgedreht. Wäre das heute so
angehypt wie damals, hätte der mehrere Millionen
Abos. Das ist genauso wie der Azitoni.
Hätte der Azitoni damals Youtube
Videos gemacht, hätte der auch
paar Millionen Abos und könnte davon
leben. Die waren einfach zu früh.
Ja, das ist okay. Das dritte Allega-Cover.
Headbang-Time.
Darkness.
Wie auch immer die Lyrics
gehen. Irgendwas mit Darkness.
Dieses Aiming ist so schlimm anzusehen.
Warum? Das ist halt
Xbox 360
Aiming ist doch okay. Dafür ist es doch ganz
nice.
Und er hat... Wenigstens hat er das
richtig gemacht. Er hat den Controller schon nicht so
so schnell eingestellt. Deswegen trifft
er auch so gut. Die ganzen Noobs haben damals gedacht,
sie müssen alle Face
20er Sens Kreisel-Sachen
anstehen. Einstellen.
Sandy spielt invertiert.
Ich auch.
Revealed.
Invertiert
beste.
Nur die waren pro spielen invertiert.
Ich kann nicht...
Ich kann nicht spielen ohne invertiert.
Invertiert Controller
Settings beste.
Ist das normal?
Dass es jetzt wieder von vorne anfängt?
Oder habe ich gerade geklickt?
Ah, ich habe geklickt.
Lull. Alter. Lull.
Lull.
So, was macht eigentlich mein Video?
Ist es mittlerweile verarbeitet?
Nein. 360p.
Ja, fuck.
Okay, naja, gut. Also das Video kommt wahrscheinlich
erst so 16 Uhr oder sowas. Das heißt, es kann auch
ein bisschen verarbeiten.
Okay, Leute. Wie lange bin ich denn schon on?
Zwei Stunden, eine Minute.
Ich habe Hunger, sage ich euch.
Ich habe übertrieben Hunger.
Ich habe mich früher immer gefragt, wer invertiert
spielt, bis zu einem Videoklass.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich kann nicht
normal spielen. Ich muss invertiert spielen.
So.
Was empfiehlt uns YouTube denn heute noch?
When a noobtuber
gets taste of their own
noobtube?
Medicine. Okay.
Der Lego-Typ wieder.
Spinning a Lego
wheel faster.
Wir müssen uns jetzt nochmal... Guck mal, ich kriege meine eigenen Videos
empfohlen. Poggers.
Timestamp für IT-Gehälter.
Irgendwo.
Da so.
Max, du bist ein Ehrenmann.
So sieht's aus.
Diese Schwarzgefahren trotz Fahrschein
wird mir auch empfohlen.
Yeah.
Moment, was?
Javelin-Tactical-Nuke?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Da ist irgendein Trick dabei.
Haben wir das nicht schon mal geguckt?
Der macht 7 Kills
und Harrier 100 pro. Ja.
Ja klar, weil es Modern Warfare ist.
Weil es Modern Warfare ist. Da ging das halt.
Müssen wir trotzdem. Javelin.
Javelin. Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Javelin Moab.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, Leute.
Da ist die Moab.
Oh Mann.
Oh, da hat er mal Glück gehabt.
Oh, Alter.
Übertreib halt mit deinem Intro.
Was geht ab?
PTF.
Alter, was ist mit dem?
Ach, das ist Ali A.
Hä?
Warum hat der Ali A davor gemacht?
Ich glaube, der verarscht den.
Ich glaube, der wollte den verarschen,
den Typ.
Der wollte den verarschen.
Ah, verstehe. Gibt es den überhaupt noch?
Das war doch ein Meme.
Ich kann nicht jedes bescheuerte Meme kennen.
Ich kenne schon mehr als genug.
Trotz Big Brain passt irgendwann nicht mehr rein.
Bambi.
Ohoho.
Okay, da musst du einfach nur lange spielen
und Glück haben, dass das funktioniert.
Deine Mutter.
Oder was sagt er da?
Hört sich immer an wie deine Mutter.
Mach es gut, Sibaro.
Bambi, deine Mutter.
Oh mein, das hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Wollt ihr nicht besser Scavenger oder...
Okay, einfach
Javelin in your face, Top Haganah, fertig.
Easy.
Easy Nuke, easy life.
What?
Warum hat er jetzt geraged quittet?
Almost, I don't even know,
almost 5000 likes already.
As I promised, 2000 likes
and we would drop a Javelin Nuke
and today I got something very special for you.
So if you guys have any more challenges,
leave them down in the comments below.
Be sure to subscribe if you're brand new.
We'll be posting a ton more Modern Warfare 2 content.
And we're probably gonna do some more streams as well.
Dann haben wir Glück gehabt,
dass das Ding nicht gegen die Decke geflogen ist.
It did take me extremely, extremely long to get this.
That is also why I haven't uploaded
or streamed in five days.
Hopefully you guys do enjoy the video.
I believe this is the only Javelin
tactical Nuke of 2018.
Or backwards compatible.
So I guess you could say it is some type of record.
But nonetheless, hopefully you guys do enjoy the video.
I'm out. Peace out everyone.
So viele Nukes kann man echt nur auf der Konsole machen.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Also ich mein, mittlerweile schon,
weil du Modern Warfare auf dem PC nicht mehr spielen kannst.
Modern Warfare 2, richtig.
Auch modded? Ja, leider.
Leider.
Leider sind die alten Kot-Teile.
Ich hab's ja mal ein bisschen probiert.
Also Modern Warfare 2 hab ich gar nichts mehr gefunden.
Nuke ist 25 Kills.
Black Ops 1 hab ich noch ein bisschen was gefunden.
Paar Free For Alls noch erspielt.
Aber der Sound vom Javelin find ich cool.
Bam.
In your face.
Franker Faces.
Ich glaube das war...
Oh fuck.
Das war glaube ich ein sehr frustrierendes...
Das war glaube ich sehr frustrierend für ihn.
Das zu erspielen.
Was? Keiner redet von Modern Warfare 2019?
Was?
Ne, ne, ne.
Ja.
2019 ist es Gunstreak.
Only 30 Kills.
Und...
Wir haben halt 25 mit Killstreaks.
Deswegen war es auch relativ einfach.
Was ist eigentlich Leute?
Wisst ihr was aus...
Alter IW-Net geworden ist?
Beziehungsweise im Nachfolger?
Es gab doch irgendeinen Nachfolger.
Green Star 388.
Ey, let's go, let's go.
IW-V-Net, ja.
Spielen das noch viele?
Alright, here we go.
I feel like this might be another good spot.
Running right out of here.
Yeah, I don't want to kill myself.
Usually they tend to run out over here.
So maybe we'll get a quick kill before we can get a shopper.
Alright, nice.
IW-VX, okay.
We might actually get this right here.
Oh, I'm going down here.
Might as well start hiding now.
Let's go, come on.
Let's do this, come on.
Dude, already getting shot down?
Are you kidding me?
Yo, just the thing is.
Yo, some of you guys are gonna rip on me.
Tell me, yo, you literally got 7, 8 kills with a javelin.
You gotta understand that these people are literally
spamming stingers.
We might be able to get this though.
Dude, we're so close.
I gotta be careful getting back up here because
if I fall off the map needing 4 more kills.
Oh my gosh, dude.
But yeah, as I was saying guys, it is
I wanna say 100%
possible to get 25 gun kills
with a javelin only by yourself.
Picking up scavenger packs and running
around and just searching, it's just impossible.
If you guys can get a video
25 gun kills with a javelin only, go for it.
And when you're done, I literally want you
to send it to me if you can do it.
So before you hate, I just want you guys to understand
that it's like near impossible.
Let me get the scavenger pack.
That was just so clutch that it was standing there.
Let's see what we can do.
Please, please, don't kill myself.
Here we are.
I need more scavenger packs though, dude.
This must echt mega frustrierend gewesen sein.
Javelin-Jungs.
It's just, it's gonna be tough.
The fact that I need a scav pack right now
and there's no one even near me, it just kinda screws me.
Sollte javelin plus noobtube nuke machen.
Run out, come on.
Gotta go for the knife.
Ach, knife ist erlaubt.
Okay.
Oh, Miss Knife erlaubt in a javelin only nuke.
Und claymore kills auch.
We literally need two more kills, dude.
And I have two javelin shots, we definitely got this.
Come on, retreat back.
Take a nice shot over here.
Please, please, just help me out.
Please, come on.
Vorbei geschossen.
I could try and shoot it in the house and it go through the ceiling.
I think I might.
This is sketchy though, cause I could get shot.
Alright, we gotta go for it.
It's gonna come in the roof when I get it there, so we gotta try this.
We gotta try this.
Der wird jetzt gekillt.
Fuck.
Oh my god.
Scheiße.
Oh my god, dude.
The wasteland usually isn't the best map for this javelin here,
but I really did find this spot
that works almost every time shooting to be ready.
It's like right through these bushes
and it locks onto this little, little tree spot, I think so.
I gotta try to get it, come on.
It really, dude, it's really been skilling, too.
Da kann man anlocken.
There it is, there it is.
Watch it, I guarantee you we get the kill.
Bam, bam.
I literally called it, you got that nice scavenger pack right there.
Yo.
We might be able to just keep doing this.
I mean, if they're not supporting us, we might as well just keep shooting them up over here
and we keep getting kills like this.
Oh, this is not good right now.
I don't wanna run in there and die,
but I keep, obviously I need the scavenger pack.
There's another kill, dude.
If I can keep getting a kill every time I do this,
I'm golden.
It's just sketchy running back in here.
Look at me, I'm a sniper, bro.
Gotta do what you gotta do.
There's another kill right there, we're just lining them up.
Lock on, please, lock on for me, please.
Sometimes it does this and I literally can't lock on.
Javelin acts in weird ways, but I know if I get another shot off right now...
Oh, dude, this might be a good kill right here.
I'm turning their AWP on, you're sitting there,
where we're gonna catch a snake.
Harriers, let's go, come on, come on, dude.
I've literally been working for like four or five days now,
I'm literally only using a javelin.
No kills with my Harriers.
If you guys have seen me online,
I'm not kidding, I literally use a javelin
every single lobby for like five days now.
If my Harriers can get these kills, it'd be great.
There's one.
I'm not even kidding, I probably spent like
15 to 20 in-game hours
with a javelin.
Oh, nice Claymore kill.
Dude, this could be it. If my Harrier gets one more kill,
we could have this. There's no stinger yet.
The thing is, I haven't had any of this type of luck.
Yo, let's go.
My luck has been absolutely terrible.
Buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh.
Uh oh.
We gotta go quick, dude.
Come on.
Sag mal, ist er gestorben? Ist er gestorben gerade?
We could easily have this.
Oh yes, come on. Oh, oh, no, come on.
Dude, please.
Oh, stinger.
Yes, let's go. Oh my god, dude.
Borgers.
Yo, it legitimately took me like
four or five days. This is why I have it up
loud called the stinger. I really do not care.
Yes, I know you guys are gonna
complain seven, eight, nine kills, whatever
with the javelin, bro. Deswegen guck ich die Videos von ihm
immer gerne. Das ist nicht, das ist keine große Show
oder so, das zeigt einfach nur Gameplay.
Also Leute, falls ihr ihn noch nicht abonniert habt, abonniert
ihn, das ist echt nice zu gucken.
You have no idea. Guck mal, Fanto ist da.
Was macht, ähm,
was machen die Zähne? Beziehungsweise,
naja, Zähne ist falsch gesagt. Was,
was macht das übrig gebliebene,
wo die Zähne mal waren?
Just use a javelin, bro.
It's insane. Und er hat
gemessert. Nur so ist legit Nuke, ne? Also ihr
erinnert euch noch in MW2.
Wer nicht gemessert hat zur Nuke,
der hat die Nuke aberkannt bekommen.
Drop a like if you guys did enjoy the video.
Er hat einen Ticken zu früh gemessert.
The like will be greatly appreciated.
Das müsste noch mal der Zentralrat
der, keine Ahnung, Nuke-Überprüfer
mal checken, ob das eine legit Nuke war,
ohne das passende Messer-Timing.
Natürlich,
Stufe 1. Abonniert 3 Monate.
Big Brain Sub. Poggers.
Muss mal gucken, ob ich Subs übersehen hab.
Leverlucky hatten wir schon und
Daniel Lull davor hatten wir auch schon. Perfekt.
Haben wir nichts übersehen.
Huge Brain. Leute, ich muss mal gucken, was
der Video macht. Ob der Kram jetzt endlich
verarbeitet ist.
Da wartet er bis 16 Uhr Zeit und
er ist 360p.
Nice.
Warum ist YouTube eigentlich so langsam
im Verarbeiten die letzten Tage?
Das ist der Wahnsinn, ey.
Ich hab gestern, vorgestern, 3 Stunden,
4 Stunden gewartet auf ein Video,
gestern 4 Stunden gewartet auf ein Video
und heute ist der Upload auch schon wieder
eine Stunde fertig und tut sich nix.
Okay, heute verstehe ich, weil
das Video heute ist auch, ähm,
ich sag's euch, das Video
heute ist ja auch
51 Minuten
30 Sekunden lang. Alter, warum ist das
so lang?
So Leute, sind wir wach?
Sind wir wach?
Hab ich euch eigentlich schon erzählt, was ihr tolles machen könnt?
Ich hab ja vorher schon mal angefangen. Was ihr tolles machen könnt
mit eurem Amazon
Prime Account.
Ja, 51 Minuten.
Da kann man schon mal einen Prime
Sub reinhauen, denk ich.
Für 51 Minuten Modern Warfare.
Äh, Spaß,
51 Minuten Modern Warfare 2009
Fazit. Falls ihr nämlich
einen Amazon Account habt, könnt ihr das ganze
verbinden mit eurem Twitch Account
und einen Streamer eurer Wahl, also
es muss nicht ich sein, ja.
Ihr könnt auch zum Funtube gehen oder zu irgendjemand anderem
und könnt ihr einmal
im Monat kostenlos,
also quasi auf Amazons Nacken,
wie man heutzutage so schön sagt,
ähm, einen Streamer eurer Wahl mit einem
Tier 1 Sub unterstützen.
Das kostet euch nix.
Und ihr kriegt alle Vorteile, was Emotes
und Sub Badges und sowas angeht
und das Streamer auch. Und ihr müsst dafür nix
bezahlen, also es, äh
Twitch Prime Sub
verschimmeln lassen ist, ähm
definitiv nicht Big Brain, sondern
eher sehr Small Brain.
Und es möchte natürlich keiner Small Brain sein.
Boracios Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Funktioniert schon.
So, ähm
Eigentlich bin ich wach,
Leute, wie sieht's bei euch so aus? Seid ihr auch
wach schon? Nein.
Das ist Fangfrage,
weil,
weil wenn man sagt, ja,
dann würde ja bedeuten, ich kann den Aufwachstream
ausmachen.
Ups. Ich mein, wir waren heute ein bisschen
später, wir waren heute ein bisschen später
und sind vielleicht auch ein bisschen kürzer
on, nur zwei, nur, nur, ja,
nur zwei Stunden zwanzig.
Geht direkt
über zum Mittagstream. Ich muss meiner
Katz jetzt was zu essen machen. Ich glaub, die ist schon
ganz schön angepisst, wenn ich jetzt hier
gleich, gleich rausgehe aus meinem
Arbeitszimmer. Außerdem hab ich Hunger.
Das ist die Moab.
Okay, wir gucken mal.
Vielleicht empfiehlt uns YouTube irgendwas Gutes.
Cheap Lego Wheel Spins.
Der Auer hat ein neues Video.
500 Megahertz RAM. Braucht
das irgendjemand? Abusing
Unlimited Google Drive. Okay,
das hab ich schon mal irgendwann gesehen.
Okay, da bin
ich jetzt mal gespannt.
60 Hertz versus 144
versus 240.
Die Wahrheit über Refresh Rate.
Okay, was ist das neueste
Linux-Techtipps-Videos?
Let's get this.
64-Core Epic.
Braucht kein Mensch. Im Heimbereich.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Weil ihr wisst ja, ich halte das alles,
alles für unsinnig.
Weil es ist ja allgemein bekannt,
wenn man da mal neuesten Studien glaubt,
dass das menschliche Auge eh nur 12
FPS sieht. Also alles,
alles unsinnig, ja.
Und 24 halt mit zwei Augen.
Deswegen ist das alles
unsinnig. Der einzige Grund, warum
ich den 144, beziehungsweise
auch 200
Hertz Monitor hab, ist, weil ich gerne Geld
ausgebe. Bringen tut das nix.
Das ist genauso wie RGB.
RGB bringt ja auch nix,
aber die Leute kaufen sich trotzdem RGB.
Starmac.
Zwei Monate. Poggas, danke.
Manche sehen auch 0 FPS
aus beiden Augen.
Ja, das ist halt die Frage. Ist das Auge
kaputt? Oder ist das Brain
zu klein, um was zu sehen?
Das kann ja beides sein. RGB
bringt nichts.
Tja. Die Wahrheit
schmerzt manchmal, ja.
Das ist genauso, wie alles über
800x600 Auflösung
nix bringt. Was meint ihr,
warum die ganzen CSGO Pros
in so komischen Auflösungen
spielen?
Einfach heute, heute einfach mal Realtalk.
Ich sag, wie es ist, ja.
Höhere Auflösung ist umsonst
und mehr als 12 FPS
ist auch umsonst.
Ok, gucken wir uns das ganze mal an.
Ey, sitzt wirklich irgendjemand
so vorm Monitor und spielt Overwatch?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Niemand sitzt so vorm Rechner und spielt Overwatch.
Das ist ja fast so wie dieser
Typ, ähm,
das ist ja fast so wie dieser Dude hier.
Dear Mr. Scully,
Mac rules the world.
Your Mac-Friend, Brent Amber.
Ok, nicht ganz so schlimm,
ja.
Alter Leute, ihr diskutiert jetzt nicht ernsthaft drüber,
ob das stimmt, was ich gesagt hab mit 12 FPS
im Chat, oder?
Ich dachte, ich dachte, wir haben High-IQ-Chat.
Das ist ja, äh,
Wahnsinns-Pepega-Diskussion, ey.
Stoll.
You've got to make it.
It can even give you a competitive advantage.
Aiming feels more precise.
Feedback from your inputs feels more immediate.
And you can react faster,
thanks to the reduced latency and blur.
Although even all of this
can't make up for my fairly terrible
gaming skills.
Hey, guys, I'm TomatekJab, and I've teamed up
with Nvidia and also eBuyadog
to bring you this video,
which is all about showing you the
real-world gaming benefits
of a higher... So nennt man das also.
Teamed up with Nvidia.
Das ist kein
Sponsored-Video, er, er, er hat nur,
er ist nur, nur team-upped mit Nvidia.
Das mach ich, das sag ich
das nächste Mal auch so. Ich sag das nächste Mal
nicht, gesponsored, gesponsored
von Ubisoft, gesponsored von Nvidia,
oder sowas, ich denk mir da irgendwie
ein bisschen schönere Umschreibung aus.
Ja.
So nach dem Motto,
ich hab mich mit Ubisoft zusammengesetzt
und das neueste Ubisoft ge...
Egal.
...
But having said that, if you can, I'd definitely try and see this in person for yourself.
Maybe you can go to an electronic store and maybe they'll have one to show you or a friend's house
because really you do have to see it in person to get the full experience.
Now to show you what I mean, let's look at some side-by-side game footage
at 144Hz, 1440p and 240Hz at 1080p.
Mach doch erstmal, Alter, mach doch Motion Blur erstmal aus.
... have a media capture card.
So it's pretty clear, especially in slow motion,
quite how smooth movement and actions are compared to 60Hz.
And at full speed, this can genuinely transform how a game plays.
It's all.
To be clear, while a refresh rate is the number of frames the monitor can display in a second,
the actual number of frames you'll see, your FPS, will depend on the game,
the graphic settings and how powerful your PC is.
But we'll come back to this.
So why does it make a difference?
Well, for every frame on a 60Hz screen, we get 2.4 frames with a 144Hz monitor
and 4 frames with a 144Hz monitor.
This means gameplay can be much smoother.
And the step-up from 60Hz to 144Hz is a huge improvement.
Riesenunterschied, ja klar.
Although the change from 144Hz to 240Hz is not as obvious,
ist trotzdem ein Unterschied.
In either case, it makes a big difference,
particularly in fast-paced, competitive multiplayer games.
So it's smoother and it looks nicer,
but can a high-refresh monitor actually make you win more in games?
Ja, ja, ja, ja, auf jeden Fall.
... times are important as well.
In any gaming monitor, but so is the framerate.
The time between frames at 60Hz adds a lot to the lag you perceive
between clicking the mouse and seeing the result on screen.
Also hier am Gaming-Rechner habe ich einen BenQ 144Hz Monitor dran.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, welches Modell genau.
Ist schon ein bisschen älter.
So as the time between frames at higher refresh rates is lower,
the action appears on the screen quicker.
NVIDIA actually ran a recent study where they found players with higher framerates
got better overall win ratio.
Oh nee!
Es kommt mir nicht mit dieser NVIDIA-Studie.
Da habe ich doch schon mal ein Video zu gemacht.
Es kommt mir nicht damit, wo NVIDIA rausgefunden hat,
je teurer die NVIDIA-Grafikkarte ist und umso besser sind die Leute.
For example, say an enemy is coming around the corner.
If you're getting more frames in a given second,
there's a chance you'll see them several frames earlier than you would
on a normal 60Hz screen.
Nein, nein, nicht unbedingt.
Nicht unbedingt.
And well, usually in my case, not winning.
So the higher the framerate, the better.
So the higher the framerate, the more...
Nein, eigentlich solltest du den Gegner nicht unbedingt...
Also, kommt auf das Game an,
aber du solltest den Gegner nicht unbedingt schneller sehen,
weil du 144Hz hast, beziehungsweise 60Hz hast.
Der Gegner...
Also beim Gegner sehen, beziehungsweise Gegner bewegen,
ist das gar nicht schlimm.
Du hast...
Der größte Vorteil...
Der größte Vorteil von 144 gegen 60 FPS ist,
dass die Bewegung weicher ist.
Dass du in der Bewegung, wenn du dich drehst,
wenn du dich drehst,
dass du mehr siehst vom Spiel in der Bewegung,
und dass es sich einfach flüssiger anfühlt.
Was natürlich auch ein Riesenvorteil ist,
was du merkst beim Zielen.
Es ist halt ein Unterschied,
ob dein Maus-Input 144 Mal in der Sekunde abgedatet werden kann,
im Game grafisch, oder nur 60 Mal.
Dass du Gegner früher oder später siehst,
das hängt wahrscheinlich vom Game,
aber würde ich so generell nicht unterschreiben.
Ich meine, theoretisch, vielleicht schwankt das mal um ein paar Frames,
aber an sich eigentlich nicht.
Weil ich meine, der Gegner sollte zur gleichen Zeit
auf deinem Bildschirm auftauchen.
Äh...
Maus-Input ist an die Framerate gebunden.
Naja, logischerweise, ja.
Also nicht, wie das Ingame abtastet deine Maus,
aber, dass es angezeigt wird,
ist natürlich an die Framerate gebunden.
Wenn ich meine Maus jetzt wild hin und her bewege,
wird das mit 144 öfters updated, als mit 60.
Was ich merke ingame.
Dementsprechend fühlt sich's ja auch viel...
...viel kontrollierter an mit 144, ähm...
...Herz, als mit 60.
Das reine Abtasten von der Maus,
das ist nicht an meine FPS gebunden.
Aber das, was das Spiel rendert, natürlich.
So, das stimmt.
Naja, gut, der Ghost... ähm...
Du hast einfach... Du hast einfach...
...weniger...
Ich nenn's mal...
...bläh...
...in der Bewegung, weil du halt...
...ähm...
...mehr Bilder zur Verfügung hast.
Ist deine Maus-Abtastrate 500 oder 1000?
Ich glaub 1000...
Äh...
...ich glaub 1000.
Warte mal.
Kann ich dir sagen?
Äh...
1000.
Ich verwende eh nur 800 DPI.
Den Rest...
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum der überhaupt eingestellt ist.
Maus-Invertieren...
Ne, Maus-Invertieren suckt.
Controller-Invertieren ist Big Brand.
Maus-Invertieren machen nur die Noobs, Controller-Invertieren machen die richtig guten Spieler.
Ja, das bringt's aber bei hoher Frames jetzt nur bedingt.
Wenn du 100 FPS in Apex oder PUBG bekommst, dann machst du natürlich nicht den 144 oder sogar 240 Hz-Refresh.
Trotzdem bringt's was.
Also der aktuelle Frame-Rate, den du bekommst, wird sehr viel auf die Art der Spiele, die du spielst, abhängig sein.
Offiziell können dir weniger bequeme Titel die Möglichkeit geben, diese Displays einfacher zu maxieren.
Aber wenn du grafische Intensiv-Triple-A-Title spielst...
Das mit dem Controller war...
...dann musst du wahrscheinlich dein Setup...
Nein, das mit dem Controller ist nicht ernst gemeint.
Ich spiel halt Controller, nur invertiert.
...oder investiere sogar in eine stärkere Grafik-Karte.
Aber es ist wert, dass du in Erinnerung bist, dass...
...auch wenn du den Monitor gerade nicht maxieren kannst...
...die Chancen sind, dass du...
Fairness99 sagt, wer die Abtastrate von der Maus niedriger stellt als das Maximum, das möglich ist, ist ein richtiges Big Brain.
Ja, ist es tatsächlich.
Weil wenn du beispielsweise deine Maus an der PS4 anschließt, die ja irgendwie suckt über USB...
...ist die Abtastrate tatsächlich sinnvoller runterzustellen.
Die Maus...
Ich hab's ja mit Modern Warfare auf der PS4 ausprobiert...
...stellt man die Abtastrate auf 250 oder so...
...oder was, 250 runter?
Mal gucken...
Also stellt man die...
Genau, 125...
Aber die Abtastrate auf 250 hat sich die Maus auf der PS4 viel besser gespielt als auf 1000.
Aber das ist irgendeine PS4-Geschichte.
...PC in the future, then you'll be able to take better advantage of it.
And of course, high refresh doesn't just benefit games.
Everyday desktop tasks feel much smoother, from scrolling through webpages, moving windows around...
...or even as something as simple as moving the mouse cursor...
Warum invertiert man seinen Controller?
...it'll feel smoother and more precise.
Weil ich damit besser spielen kann.
Okay, next question.
144 Hz vs. 240.
Which is better?
I mean, the answer should seem obvious, but...
Nicht Abtastrate, Polling Rate.
Also, ja...
Nee, damit ist nicht DPI gemeint.
Damit ist gemeint im Endeffekt, wie oft die Maus...
Wie oft von der Maus Änderungen abgefragt werden.
Oder geliefert werden.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer nach wem pollt, ehrlich gesagt.
I actually think 144 Hz is the better choice for most people.
Ich glaube, dass 144 Hz die bessere Wahl ist für die meisten Menschen.
Es ist euer Name gededankt!
Also ich kaufte mir in dem nächsten 240 Hz Monitor.
Also ich kaufte mir im nächsten 240 Hz Monitor.
limited to 1080p. However, if you're all about that speed, and particularly if you play less
demanding competitive games like Overwatch or CSGO, then I think you should consider
a 240Hz 1080p to get the best advantage. But you'll probably still want to dial down
some graphics settings.
...Quali-Settings braucht für 240FPS.
Ich habe irgendeinen BenQ 140Hz, ich weiß nicht, wie der heißt.
Äh, Cotton Cori, doch. Klar, kommst du auf 240FPS. Du musst einfach die Quali runterstellen.
Deswegen spiele ich ja alle Online-Games immer in Augenkrebs-Qualität.
...dass ich viel FPS habe. FPS-Beste.
Was gibt's denn da gerade so? Ja, okay, wir haben's verstanden. Ähm, was gibt's denn
da gerade so? Was, was, was, was lohnt sich denn da gerade? Was hat, was sagt denn PC Games?
Was sagt denn PC Games Hardware zu? Den traue ich da immer ganz gut zu.
Ähm, Kaufberater.
...Kaufberatung, gucken wir doch mal. Kaufberatung, äh, wo sind die Monitore? Ah ja, da passt
doch. Gaming Monitor Test 2019. LCD, Full HD, äh, Wide, äh, Dings HD, Ultra, äh, Dings
HD, äh, 4K, äh, 24, äh, 21 zu 9, äh, 21 zu 9 brauche ich nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ich
finde, dass G-Sync jetzt nicht so der krasse Game Changer ist, was draus gemacht wird bei
hohen Framerates. Hält sich, finde ich, in Grenzen.
Ich habe meinen G-Sync Monitor sogar verkauft vor einer Weile. Ich hatte, ich hatte ja einen
G-Sync Monitor. Das Problem war von, von, von A, A, AOC oder so. Den habe ich damals von
Nvidia gekriegt und der war gut. Der hat mir im Prinzip besser gefallen als mein BenQ Monitor.
Die Sache dabei war bloß, ähm, die Farben bei dem Ding sahen so kacke aus. Ich bin ja
auch jemand, der seinen, seinen Monitor kalibriert, ja. Big Brain Move. Übrigens, wer sich fragt,
wie man einen Monitor kalibriert, das ist ja auch so. Ich bin ja auch jemand, der seinen, seinen
Monitor kalibriert, ja. Big Brain Move. Übrigens, wer sich fragt, wie man einen Monitor
kalibriert, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es jetzt was Neues gibt. Da könnt ihr euch sowas hier
kaufen. The best Spider ever. Sag mal, die Seite lädt nicht wirklich. Das ist so ein
Ding, das hängt hier vom Monitor, schließt ein paar USB an, dann zeigt es halt verschiedene
Farben im Hintergrund an. Das Ding misst, wie die Farben aussehen und dann kommt ein Farbprofil
raus, ähm, das mit dem ihr euren Monitor kalibrieren könnt. Das ist wirklich nice.
Und ich habe versucht, das Ding zu kalibrieren, diesen, diesen G-Sync Monitor, den ich hatte.
Das sah scheiße aus. Wenn du gute Farben haben willst, ist 240 Hertz. Ich brauche keine
Top-Farben. Ich brauche Farben, die, wo, wo Rot nach Rot wenigstens aussieht. Und Gelb
nicht nach Blau und sowas. Und eher nicht nach Grün. Ich bin da gar nicht so anspruchsvoll.
Ich, ich, deswegen kalibriere ich die Dinger, dass sie halbwegs in die Richtung kommen. Und
das Ding war so schlecht von den Farben her, das hat, das, das konnte ich mit Kalibrieren
nicht mal, nicht mal richtig verwenden. Habe ich dann verkauft. Okay, also, was empfiehlt
uns denn PC Games Hardware? Geht das auch für den TV? Ja, klar. Ähm, du musst ja bloß
gucken, es gibt zwei Varianten. Du kannst entweder mit einem Farbprofil kalibrieren,
wo du bei, wahrscheinlich beim Fernsehen kannst du kein Farbprofil laden, aber du kannst auch
kalibrieren mit dem Ding und halt immer wieder laufen lassen und die Farben kontrollieren
und dann am Fernseher rumstellen. Das geht auch. Ja, also ich, ich denke auch bei vielen,
bei hohen Frames ist G-Sync jetzt nicht so das Ding. Wahrscheinlich wird der nächste
Monitor, den ich mir hole, tatsächlich nicht so das Ding. Aber, aber, aber, aber, aber, aber,
aber, aber, aber, aber, aber, aber, aber, aber, aber, aber, aber, aber, aber,
Der AORC. Wieso? Kann Nvidia jetzt eigentlich auch Free Sync oder kann nur AMD Free Sync?
Ja. Beide. Ui. Na, Gott sei Dank. Ja. IFPS Gaming. Zwei sind auf dem Markt. Jawohl. Auf Kosten der Bildqualität.
E-Sync.
Welche der Input Lag ist das?
Ja, okay, wenn, sag mal so, wenn sich Grafikkarte und Monitor synchronisieren, wann welches Bild rausgeschickt wird,
hab ich mir nie Gedanken zu gemacht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es zu Input-Lag führt, den man fühlen kann.
Okay, was empfehlen sie denn da?
Moin, ACDX, was empfehlen sie hier?
Haben die auch eine Tabelle?
Rauschunterdrückung für Mikrofone.
Igitt!
Also erstens, warum hab ich einen Monitor mit Rauschunterdrückung für Mikrofone?
Und warum hab ich ein Mikrofon, wo ich überhaupt Rausch unterdrücken muss?
Gaming, Rauschunterdrückung, Leute, das brauchst du nur, wenn du irgendwelchen Gamer, Audio-Bullshit-Gamer-Zeug kaufst.
Dann brauchst du Rauschunterdrückung.
Sowas Blödsinniges.
Okay, also die sagen, der ist relativ gut.
KD25F.
Kostet 550 Euro.
Oh, das ist von MSI gewesen, oder?
Von MSI hab ich keine...
Ah, nee, Gigabit.
Okay, Gigabyte.
Da hätte ich vielleicht sogar eine Chance, wenn ich da rumnerve,
dass man da irgendwie mal eine...
Wie hat er gesagt?
Dass ich mit denen teamuppen könnte.
Und den Monitor zeigen, ja?
Mit MSI hab ich keine Chancen, weil MSI...
Hat mich gebannt.
Und ich weiß, ich erzähl's ja immer wieder, aber ich weiß bis heute nicht, warum.
Hier gibt's die offizielle Nvidia-Liste.
Na gut, das war ich dich bestimmt nicht für.
Okay, also der ist anscheinend nicht schlecht, wenn ich das so sehe.
Was kostet der auf Amazon?
Liefer nach Oberursel, ja, auf geht's.
Moment, ist das ein anderer?
Hadi?
Ist das ein anderer?
Ja, warum die Namen von...
Monitoren so beknackt sind, weiß ich auch nicht.
Mittlerweile sind aber weitere Modelle.
Der Asus ROG Swift.
Gibt es eigentlich...
Gibt es 240 Hertz mit 1044p?
Warum hatte ich MSI?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Gibt nur Full HD.
Auch vieles Batman.
Dann gucken wir uns mal die offizielle Nvidia-Spec-Liste an.
Size, ne?
Das braucht keiner.
Kann man das nicht sortieren?
Hier.
Da.
I.
Äh.
Refresh rate.
Come on, bruh.
Okay, 240.
Gibt es da irgendwas?
Nein, gibt es nicht.
Dann wird es wieder in Full HD.
Dann gibt es wieder in Full HD.
Das einzige, was es noch als Alternative gäbe, wären 165 Hertz.
Nee, ich upgrade nicht von einem 144 Hertz Monitor Full HD auf einen weiteren Full HD oder auf den...
Also mir ist mehr...
FPS, beziehungsweise mehr Hertz ist mir da wichtiger.
Ja, aber ich will ja kein 144 Hertz.
Das Wichtige ist auf jeden Fall...
240 Hertz will ich haben.
Kommt wieder Kaufberatungsvideo, weiß ich nicht.
Mal gucken.
Vielleicht mache ich mit Hardwarerad was zu Weihnachten.
Lenovo Legion.
Oh, die Dinger haben Namen, Alter.
Wer hat sich...
Wer denkt sich das aus?
Easy.
1634 Euro.
Haben wir noch ein paar Prime-Subs am Start?
Es ist vielleicht ein bisschen teurer, das ganze Ding.
Ein Schnapper, ja.
1000 Euro.
Ah, das ist mir dann doch ein bisschen teurer.
Dann, also dafür würde ich mir schon eher diesen 4K-144-Hertz-Monitor von Asus kaufen, der den Lüfter braucht.
Aber das klingt doch eigentlich nach einem ganz guten Gesamtpaket hier.
Also ich...
27 Zoll ist mir...
Ich will wieder einen 24 Zoll.
24 Zoll ist gut.
Ich sitz...
Wie gesagt, mein Schreibtisch ist jetzt nicht so tief.
Und ich sitz relativ nah am Monitor.
Alles, was größer wird, sehe ich, wenn ich unten links hingucke, nicht mehr oben rechts.
24 Zoll ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Okay.
Also, dann haben wir hier noch einen Asus ROG Swift.
Was kostet der?
Okay, das kostet alles um so 500 Euro.
Gucken wir mal, war geil, zahls.
Die Call of Duty Black Ops Edition.
Das ist vielleicht sogar Big Brain Move, sich jetzt die Black Ops 4 Edition zu kaufen, weil den will keiner mehr haben.
Ah, ne, doch.
Ja, ja, 528, das geht doch.
Hast du eine Vorliebe bei den Panels?
Naja, mir wird für 240 bei nichts anderes als TN-Panel übrigbleiben.
Ich bin aber auch...
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich bin nicht so der Riesen-Monitor-Pro, was die Technik da angeht.
Ich kenn mich da nicht so gut aus.
Das einzige, was ich halt immer mache mit meinen Monitoren, ist, die werden einmal kalibriert.
Dass die Farben wenigstens halbwegs gescheit aussehen.
Aber das war's.
Also, was kriegen wir denn für 528?
Da gucken wir uns mal ein Review an.
Haben die auch bestimmt ein Review.
Da.
Ähm.
Asus RockSwift.
Die Namen von den Dingern immer, Alter.
Bildqualität und Fazit.
Asus RockSwift PEG258Q.
Warum haben Monitore eigentlich immer so total bescheuerte Namen?
Okay.
Bildqualität.
Qualität TN-Panels haben sich in den letzten Jahren...
Okay.
Das ist doch schon mal schön.
Der hat sogar gute Farbwerte.
Ja gut.
Fernseher haben, vor allem Sony-Fernseher, haben auch wirre, wirre Namen.
22 Hertz flüssige Bildwiedergabe.
Der sagt, ab 22 Hertz wird es ansatzweise flüssig empfunden.
Und nicht als Einzelbilder.
Das heißt nicht, dass es flüssig ist.
Trotz Hoffnung durchs überdimensionierten Leuchtdichte ist die Ausleuchterbildfläche recht gleichmäßig.
Okay.
Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Da guckst du nicht unten und oben hin und unten brauchst du Sonnenbrille und oben, ne?
Input-Lag.
Der Input-Lag messen wir mit einem kleinen Apparat der Englischen.
Ist jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Okay, das habe ich den Satz...
Der Absatz ist mir zu big brain.
Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht, was der für Input-Lag hat?
Egal.
Für immer bessere TN-Qualität.
Die IPS-Mittelklasse wird schmaler.
Okay, jetzt im...
Okay.
Das klingt auch gar nicht schlecht.
Warum sind 144 FPS nicht genug?
144 FPS sind genug.
Aber warum sollte man sich mit 144 zufrieden geben, wenn man auch 240 haben kann?
Oder?
Den Asus-Golden mit G-String, meinst du den, den ich mir gerade angeguckt habe?
Achso, PS, nicht FPS.
Ey, da ist es ja genauso.
Ähm...
Wie da bin ich denn eigentlich jetzt schon an?
Mal gucken.
200, 200 Minuten.
Ich muss mal echt langsam was essen, Leute.
Ich hab übelst, übelst Kohl da.
Aber der Monitor macht einen guten Eindruck.
Vielleicht, vielleicht hole ich mir den.
Was, den AW2-Dingspa?
Okay, Review PC Games.
PC Games Hardware ist für mich der beste, beste Review.
Der A...
Ach, das ist ein Alien...
Ne, Alienware bekaufe ich mir nicht.
Alienware ist irgendwie so eine Hersteller.
Da habe ich gewisse Abneigung dagegen.
Aber vielleicht ist der ganz gut.
Kann ja sein.
Vielleicht ist der echt ganz gut.
Ne, das ist Forum, ne?
Aber Alienware nicht.
HP.
Ne, HP ist Omen.
Dell.
Genau.
Worts.
Dell ist das.
Ja, das ist auch eine Alternative.
Hehe.
Der hier.
Der ist auch cool.
Ähm...
Aber, der ist halt ein bissl teuer.
Wenn ich in Richtung Auflösung gehen würde, würde ich mir das hier holen.
Allerdings nicht für den Preis, ne?
Das ist quasi ein 4K, der 144 Hertz kann.
Das heißt, im Zweifelsfall kannst du sagen, ich spiele einfach auf niedrigerer Auflösung.
Wenn ich 144 Hertz wähle, um Desktop-Betrieb mache ich 4K.
Das ist eigentlich ein Monitor, den ich mir schon lange gewünscht habe, sowas.
Aber, es ist mir trotzdem ein bisschen teuer, ehrlich gesagt.
Nicht so, dass man sich das nicht kaufen könnte, aber ich sehe es irgendwo nicht ein.
Ich sehe es nicht ein, 2.000 Euro, 2.300 Euro auszugeben für eben einen Monitor.
Das muss echt nicht sein.
500 Euro ist okay, aber 2.300 muss echt nicht sein.
Hehe.
Wir könnten uns dafür auch noch ein iMac holen für 15.000 Euro.
Okay, Leute, schön, dass ihr alle dabei gewesen seid.
Ich muss jetzt unbedingt was futtern, ich habe übelst Hunger.
Wir sehen uns beim Video heute.
Mal gucken, ob das verarbeitet ist.
Ich schau mal schnell, ob es verarbeitet ist.
Big Brain Video-Verarbeitung.
Wie sieht es aus?
Und, nein, es ist noch nicht verarbeitet.
Ich hoffe, dass es bis 16 Uhr oder so wenigstens fertig verarbeitet ist.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich gehe jetzt was futtern, Leute.
Macht's gut.
Ich mache jetzt keine Einschlafmusik, weil das war ja ein Aufwach-Stream.
Also, ich denke mal, es kommt wahrscheinlich Raid zu German.
Könnte man echt machen.
Das da oder das da?
Das da.
Da empfehle ich das Kommentar aus zu bezeichnen Events.
Okay, also, Leute.
Hosten wir ein paar Speedrunner.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut.
Bis denn.
See you.
Das funktioniert das mit Raiden.
Okay.
Poggers.
Bis denn.
Macht's gut.